Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
I'm a little, a little eepy today.
So, um, it'll be, I'm waiting for my coffee to kick in.
And that's why I sound very, well, it has to be very, there you go.
Hello.
Now, now it's immersive.
But, um, I'm very tired today.
Uh, so I'm just waiting for my coffee to kick in.
I actually ordered a 20.
20 ounce i ordered 20 ounce for my caramel latte because i know i i need this like i i really really need this right now i am not okay at the moment so um i ordered 20 yeah the big boy the big boy drink the 20 ounce of coffee um so i'm hoping it'll kick in soon um but yes for those
Sorry, my brain is very slow right now, so it's going to take a while for me to formulate my sentences.
But the reason why I'm very EPI is because today, starting at 3 a.m., I was doing Vexpo, which is a VTuber convention in the UK in Birmingham.
And because of that, my panel started at 3 in the morning.
And my meeting group started at, well, my meeting group was supposed to start at five.
You know, it was supposed to.
Anyway, so to give context, so after the Gears of War stream and I had dinner, I got grabbed some dinner and I was debating should I tank it and stay up to oh yeah I forgot to be like I'm live this is how out of it I am right now my brain is not okay um all right live now okay there you go so uh so I was debating like oh do I just tank it to three in the morning and then I stay up until three.
So I was just like, maybe I can do it.
And at that time, it was like 9 p.m.
And I was like, I feel so alive.
You know, I'm like, I can take, I can take over the world.
I'm so alive.
But then I remember, you know, because I'm like, I can do this.
It's 3 a.m.
That's like child's play.
But I forgot, you know, I'm not at university anymore where, you know, I would fucking tank until 6 a.m.
morning.
Like, as if it's nothing, I'll do that back to back.
you know because i had such youthful energy inside i don't have that anymore i don't have the the naiveness and the the the excitement the what was it the endurance to destroy my health like i did in college so i don't have i don't have the university buff where i was i was so ready to destroy my health and my sleep for one day for maybe several days i feel if I feel wild but uh yeah yeah I couldn't I couldn't do that because at as soon as it as it's like you know it's like Cinderella the moment it hits midnight like it all disappears and that's what happened to me like it hit midnight and then I was like I was dead I was like I I can't I cannot keep going I cannot keep going I was like oh no I'm so so tired so at midnight the magic is all gone and so so i decided okay i'm gonna take a three hour i'll take a three hour nap and it'll be it'll be fine and it was not fine obviously i always tell that i it's a lie i tell myself i'll be like it's okay like you can do it it's just you know
the moment you take this nap you'll be fine like you'll be back to normal and that's what i tell myself like i lie to myself so naturally uh it's my little cope that like don't worry it'll be okay it was obviously not okay so i woke up um i woke up at three to get ready for like tech rehearsal because the panel stuff was at 3 30 and um it was fun it was a uh It'll be fine.
I Don't keep her.
Don't gaslight her to even myself.
So it was a great panel.
I got to meet a lot of dragoons from EU plus one Canadian dragoon who traveled all the way from Canada to be there because he was actually going to school here in the UK.
So it was meeting everybody at the panel.
And then I get like, supposedly I would get a...
a 30 minute break and then it would be the meeting tree um but uh unfortunately um which is understandable if you guys didn't like if you guys never like been into event planning in general like something will always happen because like you know you can't really account for human error or like um things you can't control um so obviously and this is like the second time they've hosted vexpo so it's very understandable that They haven't had everything figured out yet,
like a lot of variables and stuff like that.
And a lot of times, if you guys didn't notice, conventions are mostly run by volunteers, especially if it's not for profit.
So a lot of the staff, not just like Vexpo, but like a lot of conventions in general, anime conventions in general are run by volunteers, like people who are passionate about VTubers.
And so they're not paid to be staff.
They volunteered their own time to be the staff.
So obviously a lot of checks and balances.
and a lot of um you know like you know uh uh you know uh communication stuff can can go wrong because like when you know people aren't being paid for this so obviously like uh things can go wrong because there's no like account there's not really like accountability when you're like i'm doing for free bro like if i get yelled at for some as a if i was a volunteer for anything like and i give up my own fucking time like to do something and i get yelled at for it i'll be like bro you're not even paying me like come on which is very understandable like even i would be like what the fuck like i'm i'm here for free like so so it's um it's very understandable Hannibal.
So, yeah, so the meet and greet for my meet and greet, it started, I guess, like, I think it started an hour late.
So, obviously, like, because, like, there was some delays in the beginning.
There were some delays behind, like, everything was just behind schedule.
So, everyone was thinking all the meeting and stuff was incredibly behind schedule because of the delay that was going on.
um and because of that um i was supposed to end at 6 30 a.m like my meet and greet slot was supposed to end at 6 30 a.m and i was like deep time yay but it started at 6 in the morning so it didn't so um it didn't end so obviously um because it started really late um I basically stayed up three hours extra for the meet and greet because obviously it's not just me like dragoons as well had to wait in line for like two hours as well as for the meeting greet because of the delay you know they're like oh yeah be here uh be here for the meet and greet line and no well six in the morning for me like eu for them I don't even know what time it is like not really good time zones but for for eu it's not six in the morning it's thank god for them it's not six in the morning um so everything was like behind schedule i really apologize for for the delay for that um but yeah so i went to bed at around 8 30 a.m because uh because to be fair to be fair it is it is the perfect uk experience if you've
never been to the uk before and you're I want to experience the entire, you know, the entire joy of being in the United Kingdom.
And queuing is basically one of their favorite pastimes, standing in line.
So congratulations.
Congratulations.
You got to experience the United Kingdom's favorite pastime.
And standing in line for long periods of time.
It truly is a very authentic tradition.
It's a classic, the prime Birmingham experience, if you think about it.
So, you're welcome.
It is a national, yeah, the national sport of the United Kingdom.
But, yeah, so, basically, it was, we started out late.
So obviously, I feel really bad too because we started late, and then because of our delay, it caught the delay earlier.
And then the delay was building up gradually because of it, I guess because of that, every mean and grie was late then.
Because, if you delay the start, then everything will get pushed back.
So I think everything was behind schedule in general.
But I did feel really bad because a lot of dragoons were waiting for so long and um and um he said oh also like i uh the pen we were like oh what's the pen plotter the pen plotter is basically like uh there was an autograph station where um i could give you guys like a live autograph um um from a machine but for some reason mine didn't work
So basically we had to stop the meet and greet for a little bit for like five to ten minutes Because we were trying to do like tech support and being like why isn't it working?
But then after like um after my meet and greet done the next the next person the slot after me Works it worked again.
It decided to work again.
So I'm like what the fuck?
Like fuck me I guess like oh my god.
Oh like I guess I need to find a temple and go fucking wash all the, I swear, I think a spirit attached, a bad spirit attached to me, I swear to God, I am like the anti-tech right now, uh, the bad luck strikes again, so I feel really bad, because some people,
obviously, you know, some people after the meet and greet or after today, um, they have to leave or go back home, because not everybody's doing the two days, And it's just like I legitimately Googled I legitimately Googled on the internet temples where I can get spirit cleansing And I legitimately Googled that because I got so paranoid I was legitimately I was like literally thinking like Oh my god like like did a fucking spirit like attached to me or something you know like you know like those folklore where um like the like the the Asian folklore where if you visit somewhere and there's like bad spirits there they'll start like riding your shoulders and stuff and like and like cause like bad like bad luck to you wherever you go like that I was like oh my god you're right maybe I should get an online exorcism maybe I should go like on I should go on Etsy and like buy those like um spirit cleansing dolls or some remember that shit i found on etsy where they make like these voodoo dolls
and they start fucking stabbing it and stuff on it like the spirit riding crazy
how convenient i'll i'm maybe i can amazon prime my my spirit cleansing uh
So I'm just, so I'm just like thinking like, holy shit, like, I'm so, I'm so tired.
Like, I literally got, I literally got a fucking, like a CPU from Costa Rica of a, of not even a fucking CPU card.
Like I ordered an AMD card and got an Intel processor in my AMD packaging that was made 20 years ago.
Costa Rica.
Like how is, how is this real?
How is my luck like this?
Costa Rica is normal.
Yeah, the and with the motherboard still attached to it.
Like, I can't believe the motherboard was still until scam card like it was crazy um for those who don't know the story of that i talked a bit on twitter and on and on stream but i ordered this on it was the first time i've ever ordered this uh it ordered like a computer pc part online and um because i really wanted the specific um the specific cpu and then i didn't check the packaging because uh i am very naive and gullible so um so it was a harsh lesson in life and by the time i finally checked it it was already one month past the return policy and no i never got never got my money back so yeah i lost like almost nine i lost like 900 like 900 canadian dollars for it um but but i i swear If I ever do another charity auction,
I will sign this card and like auction it off for charity.
If anyone else wants a Intel processor that was made 20 years ago, still attached to a piece of its motherboard, signed by me, that's worth technically $20.
By the way, this card, you can buy it off eBay for $20.
And the thing about that card is that that card, oh, this is the worst part about this card.
But that card, you can only get it on eBay.
Like, you can't, like, because it's never sold to the public, by the way.
It was never sold to the public.
It was only for workstations.
So, like, for offices.
there uh so uh all right what was my but yeah i just couldn't believe that that happened to me but it was a very it was a very it's a very common amazon scam where they basically they basically um um order a computer part and then uh from amazon and then they basically get like those steamers where they can see okay I'm gonna teach you guys how to scam but like don't do this please don't do this or or it could happen to me again please I could be the customer that gets your fucking return package don't do this but anyway to do this you basically get those like steamers and you steam the uh you steam like the packaging stickers and everything so it's not like you rip it and so like they steam the packaging stickers so it'll come off naturally so it doesn't look like it was open and after that they just take out the packaging and get the card out and then like um and then put like whatever you know whatever like hand me down card or processor in the packaging and just like tape it all
back up because you steam the tag you steam the stickers and everything so it's not look like a rip and amazon they don't really look at what's If fucking you think the Amazon workers are paid good wages, that's very funny.
Jeff Bezos did not become a billionaire by paying good wages.
So the underpaid, the underpaid Amazon workers will just look at the packaging and be like, oh, it's not open.
It's not open.
Clearly nothing was tampered.
um because it wasn't open and they'll sell it as new they'll sell it as new to the anyone else that ordered the same thing and just ship it back to whoever and silly me for now obviously it was very fucking stupid of me to like not check the packaging but it was also my very first time ordering a cpu from amazon i never got and i haven't got scammed at that time before so i was just like i was like oh clearly this looks real because i looked up packaging I took a picture of the packaging and showed it to my friend who also had the same CPU and I was like Hey,
does this look legit?
And they're like, yeah, and I was like, okay, and I proceed to not open it for the next two months I was like, so I was like, that's good enough for me and I didn't open it for two months because I was like, I'll worry about that later
That's why that's why I didn't know.
I didn't know until I opened it and I was like, why does this say?
Why does this say Intel and made from Costa Rica?
I was like, I was so confused.
I was like, why does it, I thought this was AMD.
I thought this is AMD.
Like I'm, I'm, I'm so confused.
And then I'm like, oh, wait, wait, I think I got scammed.
why is like a piece of like a cut like it was it was like at the bottom it was really like glued to a mother like it was cut from a motherboard so it has like cut lines to it too um no it's actually attached to it it's literally um it's literally like they literally just cut the motherboard they didn't even like detach whatever the processor they cut it out of a they made a square cut from a motherboard so there's like cut scars like um surrounding from the bottom like you'd see okay i'll show you guys the photo again for those who've never seen the photo it's actually fucking crazy like for those who've never saw the photo i'll show it to you guys again um for never watched the stream let's see all right here you go here's the photo so literally that bottom part right here right here at the bottom you see that bottom that's the piece of the motherboard that that's literally a piece of the motherboard at the bottom it was fucking it was still attached to it too uh it's not even it's
not you can't even take it off like you can't even do anything with this that's the way i like i can't even do anything it's still attached to get that out of it like
so i'm just like that's why i was like bro should i go to a temple or something Because, like, because, like, before this, I literally was on a plane that we're, I swear, this year has had the most, has had the most wildest thing to ever happen to me within this,
within 2025.
I've had so many crazy shit happen to me.
And I'm like, this should not be happening to me within the year.
Producer, I haven't heard, like, my travel stories, like, last month.
I had, during my plane ride, flying back from China to Canada, the fucking pilot, during my plane ride, was like, we had to re- Good evening, passengers.
We're going to have to reroute, we're going to have to reroute the flight because a volcano erupted.
um within our flight path so we're gonna be a we're gonna have a slight delay as we figure out how um the new pathway and during my flight like a fucking volcano erupted like what the fuck were the odds of that like what did i have never had that happen i've been flying for so long And the fact that during that flight,
while I'm still in the plane, the volcano, a volcano that was in my pathway, where my path home had a volcanic eruption.
And like, I legitimately thought I was going to die.
Because I was like, holy fuck.
And then, and then before that, flying to China.
I flew in the worst rainstorm ever recorded in Hong Kong history.
And it was called the Black Rain.
That does not sound like a thing you survive in.
Like, I flew during, in the Black Rain.
That's what they called it.
The worst rainstorm in Hong Kong since the 1800s.
Like, and they called it the black rain.
And I'm like, and I flew through that.
Like,
and that was like within the week of the fucking volcanic eruption.
I took four flights in between that, like, you know, flying to Hong Kong to, and then to, guanjo and then guanjo to japan japan to canada like that was like the fact that those two the black rain and the volcanic eruption happened within a week of each other
so so i'm just thinking i'm like like and then three weeks later the fucking intel kosa rica
Sorry, the Intel processor...
Three weeks later, I had to deal with this shit!
After I survived, this shit happened to me.
This shit happened to me.
So, yeah, no.
Things have been pretty weird so far.
And 20... I survived 20-25.
t-shirt for Christmas.
Yoko, thank you for the, uh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
You know, you know, the, okay, the craziest part is that, I don't know, I talked about this before um, and, um, and basically, I talked about this on stream before, and, um, um, I don't know if anyone, you remember this twitter trend but there was like this weird twitter trend about uh correlating your birthday um finding your birthday and your um and your luck number so i think it was i don't know if it was a birthday and oh yeah i think it was a birthday yeah so you look it was a giant list a giant list of all the dates within the year and it'll be like this is how lucky you'll be in 2025 and i swear mine was on the was on the second last page and I was like like you know before 2025 started I was just like oh that's just a stupid Twitter trend that's not gonna happen I was just like that's that's just a silly Twitter trend and now I'm like Maybe not so silly and I was like guys,
I don't think it's silly anymore I How many times does this have to happen to me before it gets less silly Little does she know I swear to God it's guys it's getting less and less silly now And then Bro didn't return the slab.
Patria has said, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Because it's still a silly trend, right guys?
Is this how people start believing in horoscopes?
How many times does it have to happen to me before it gets too real?
Solid snake, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
funniest prank suitors, silliest soldiers.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Throwing some lucky away.
Really, need it.
Gladstone.
Thank you.
Maybe God just decided let there be a volcanic eruption and black storm on those days.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, guys, I'm one bad day away from becoming an astrology girl.
you don't want that for your worst enemies guys you don't want that i'm one bad day away from fucking being an astrology girl guys i'm this close i'm literally like the line is in front of me i'm getting there anything no don't join the dark side god spoken like a true leo
Anyway, anyway, there is a, um, there's a little dad update today, um, so if you guys didn't know, dad has been very, very bratty lately, um, and, uh, for those who are like, oh my gosh, what's going on, we know dogs are just like that, like, I, they just suddenly decide that,
you know, this week, I want to make your life fucking hell, like, they don't care, like, And they're just, they're just, they're literally just born this way.
Every weeder dog I've ever owned has always been incredibly bratty.
It's just their nature.
And so today, so for those who don't know, he is technically banished from using my bed.
Because obviously it's so comfy for him to sleep in my bed.
um so um but i've only i gave him one exception which is when i sleep so whenever i sleep he's allowed to sleep in my bed because then he stays in my bed but when i don't when i don't let him um while i'm sleeping my bed when i'm working it's more risky because i can't like keep an eye on him like when he wants to like because i do upstairs because i'm like i'm really worried he decided to be like he he i'm just gonna jump to the side instead of using the stairs because i'm fucking stupid um and and i love the thrill of breaking my back again he um so so like i can't monitor that when i'm working so i i just kick the stairs away and push it against the wall um and he doesn't like that uh he gets really mad whenever i do that so especially when i'm not heading to bed And I'm just,
you know, I decide to, like, just, I wanted to stay in bed and just, like, relax in bed and not sleep, like, during the middle of the day or in the morning, where I don't get up.
And, like, after I walk, dad, in the morning, and then I went, go back to bed and just lie down there for a bit, because I'm just like, it's so early.
I just want to fucking relax a little bit before I get to work.
Dad really hates that, because he's like, why do you get to sleep on the bed, and I don't?
I live here, too.
Where are my rights?
So he's like, excuse me.
I deserve to be on that bed as well.
I have the right to be here.
So does he pay rent or something?
I wish he paid rent with the way he's treating me.
It's my bed, too.
Like, he gets, he gets very demanding if I'm just lying in bed and I, and he, the stairs aren't there.
So he would like bark at me and, um, be like, uh, uh, and like, um, be like, come on, pick me up.
Put the stairs back on.
So, and or like, just like sat, like, push himself out of the top of the, like, with his front legs on the edge of the bed and like be like, come on, let me up.
Come on.
And so, like, give me my upies.
and so so recently including today because he did this a week ago but I didn't talk about it um because I forgot um but like today what he what he did was that he tried to move the stairs himself closer to the bed and like what do you mean by move the stairs he would he'd try he would all the stairs and like push it closer to the bed but he's so but he okay the best I was like I was like what is that sound honestly so confused I was like why what is he scratching because the the staircase is like up against the on the opposite side of the wall so like you know I have to like get up to after like sit up to like see the stairs so I sat up and I literally saw him Like,
just fucking up, pawing, clawing the stairs closer and closer to attach to my bed.
But, thank God, he hasn't learned how to rotate it.
And, like, what the fuck do you mean?
He hasn't learned how to rotate it.
All right, don't worry, I took a picture because I was like, what the fuck are you doing?
So, so, so, he...
he he almost got it he almost so the stair was is originally because i got him it instantly took a boy it's like what the fuck and so the stair was originally pushed up against the back of that wall guys it was and he had he pushed it all the way against my bed like that's how far he pushed it this is not what it looks like I swear to God he who did that oh how did the stairs get here oh my yeah it's so weird right that's so weird so thank God he has not yet learned how to rotate this so I about him like you know while i'm working he fucking moves the staircase himself
for being in the super chat thank you thank you old dogs can learn new tricks it's like it's like you know how okay this is why i also don't really want to get cats um because they're like oh man like oh you should get a cat because they're more low maintenance also like i don't want them to sit in my face on my face i've i've heard like stories where like it depends on a cat right but like some cats would if you don't feed them in time they try to suffocate you by like sitting on your face until you until you stop breathing and wake up and like i i don't i don't know i i just don't trust myself to like wake up so so um it really depends on your face on a cat I'm like thinking I'm thinking oh man knowing my luck I might get that type I might get that cat anyway um also that I'm worried that like I'm worried that the cat's gonna learn how to open doors because apparently I heard that it depends on the cat obviously so that I'm worried that I'm gonna get a cat that can open doors I'm
like what if I'm in the bathroom like I don't want like I don't know what if I'm in the bathroom I'm just doing my business in the bathroom and then the cat fucking opens my door like I don't want to that's weird that's just I don't want to look at my cat well I'm like why don't I look at my cat while I'm pooping like that's so weird and he just opens my door like yo so like that's just I'm worried about that open doors yet so far so the best he's just he's trying to learn how to rotate stairs that's like the lead that's the thing i have to worry about right now um i can't my bathroom door doesn't lock it that's the worst part like my bathroom door doesn't lock so i can't even do that
So, like, right now, the worst thing I have to, like, worry about from dad at the moment is him learning how to rotate the stairs.
So, like, right now, that's the worst thing I have to worry about.
And at least he's not trying to suffocate me.
So, like, at least that's, like, a plus.
Once he learns to rotate that chair, he'll rotate door handles.
so so yeah so that's the dad update for today sounds like shit design like a thank you thank you thank you um patria said thank you super chat thank you thank you thank you is that fluff from a plushie he hunted yeah he um he has so many toys and also a lot of destroyed he can't like um there's no toy he can't destroy because like i said winter dogs were meant to be hunting dogs so um so they're surprisingly very very very strong so they destroy every fucking toy you buy them even when you give them those like industrial toys that advertise are like they're basically indestructible they cannot are they very tough to chew you can fucking rip that shit apart because they're meant they're bred to be hunting they were bred to hunt badgers and badgers are like times to their size um fudge shop thank you for the super chat thank you thank you speaking of dogs have you seen the movie fix it's by the guy who made samurai jack and has it just a little but in it and it's about neutering a dog
yes it's all about extremely crude humor thank you for super chat fledged up thinking that yes i have heard about it i it was all over twitter when um it first came out and when the movie actually when the trailer first came out and i loved okay not gonna lie it's so it was so funny when i saw um when i saw like tweets being like um Oh,
what was the, what, what was the animator's name?
Um, no, I, I, I like saw the trailers and I like, I didn't watch the movie, but like, I saw the trailers and the Twitter was tweeting at the the strip club scene.
The strip club dog scene.
Um, so don't worry.
I, I know exactly what type of humor that, that movie is, but it's by Gendi.
What's isn't it?
Gendi, right?
I don't know how to pronounce his name.
Gendi.
um for those who don't know this animator is that how you pronounce his name gendi jen gendi turtakovsky turtakovsky so he has made dexter's laboratory hotel transylvania um samurai jack prima star wars clone wars he's done all that like the russian animator he also did the um the pilot the pilot pitch for Popeyes and then he released the trailer for fixed which is basically extremely crude humor about sex violence uh more sex gross humor and gore and it's all dogs and so they're like for those who are like oh it can't be that bad i think like it opens up with the dog humping the grandma's leg the main character dog humping the grandma's leg and like talking dirty to the leg so it was like extremely crude humor and then twitter exploded and was like,
how could Tartowski do that?
How could he do that?
What happened to him?
Oh my God, what a fall from grace.
And then I was like, bro, did you not?
I know, like, you can tell that they did not watch the last season of Samurai Jack or Primal because Tartowski, yeah, he's done.
like all these children animated shit but he is he had like the most repressed you can tell he was repressing a lot of the sexual jokes and the horniness he was fuck okay primal was fucking wild you can tell they never even watched primal he was holding back so much and like in the last scene of samurai he's a freak you can tell he's a freak inside he was suppressing some freakiness inside because like if you look at like all the like especially the female designs in samurai jack like that guy was you know he had like he he was suppressing a lot
opportunities like I'm gonna let it all out I mean bro okay I'll give a spoiler alert it's a really fucked up scene and also look at Dexter's mom's design also okay so um I will say that if you ever watched Prima okay I'm also I'm so sorry about the dokey jam like I'm on a really long time it right now but there's so many things i want to talk about um but if you've ever watched primal which is um his last work and i believe it's on adult swim i think at the end of primal the main okay spoiler if you guys don't want to be spoiled by primal at all i'm gonna spoil it guys um i'm gonna spoil this is a oh hbo it's on hbo so he had like a fucking he went wild with that show because he was like not restrained by corporate i guess like by corporate cartoon network or like you know by by companies at that time because hbo was like go fucking wild at that point here's like here's like five hundred thousand dollars you just do whatever you want um so he wasn't restrained at that time and even i
i think that's why like um he was so suppressed I'm pretty sure, like, the things he wanted to put on was definitely heavily censored by, like, the producers and the investors.
Because they're like, okay, okay, Tertowski, we gotta get Tertowski.
You gotta calm down.
That's what I think it was, okay, not gonna lie, I think it was good that he had less creative freedom.
Because Fix was wild.
He got a little too creative because Netflix, I would say Netflix does not care as much as other companies.
They just throw a butt because it's just, it's a streamy stream world.
Netflix does not care that much.
So like he had so much freedom to do whatever the fuck he wants.
So but basically in primal, at the end of primal, the main case.
character gets heavily burnt up where like he was just all bandages and like obviously he was gonna fucking die so and then out of nowhere his love interest was like I want a baby
in packages And then she was like and then like and then it cuts the black Child
Well, it's like what happened?
He just continued the bloodline and then obviously he's dead like he's he's not alive anymore but i was just like oh my god what the what the fuck what what if what i
have one more in me the bloodline does not end here so i was like jesus christ you're wild genedy oh my god
so so I was like Jesus Christ so for those who were like I can't believe he would make such a movie like a flop I'm like no that guy was suppressing so much he he's been waiting I would believe he's been waiting like what 30 years 30 years to do what he wanted to do yeah he he went out and a bang that's for sure um um but yeah that's basically that that i know that movie the the the clips i saw it's it's really oh my gosh i don't even know how i don't even know like how to explain it you gotta watch the clip i mean i don't even know if i should link the clips honestly
oh it was apparently in development hell for years yeah no this man was and make his dreams come true.
Um, Fletch stop.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
To be fair with Fix, there are some deep moments at the middle.
The opening filters some people and the whole movie.
So member stream.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Even during, all right oh my gosh i don't want to spoil you guys i i like saw like one moment of the d moment because i was just like what the fuck is going on so um i'll spoil a scene for you guys i like describe it but not in too detailed so the main dog has a crush on this other dog who is like a prize winning beauty contest dog and like a purebred he's a mutt you know like the typical lady in the trap stuff but like um so and the thing about for those who don't know about like dog contest usually like you know they the dog dog contest owners will do like arrange arrange sessions with their dogs if they're also award-winning dogs so they're like we're gonna create the the most beautiful um we're gonna create the most beautiful award-winning puppies with our dogs together and like it's like the horse thing you know like um you know how gold ship gets paid like a hundred grand or i don't fucking know like eight grand per session to create the best horse racers it's basically the same
with dogs for a dog contest so they do that too to get like the full purebred shit yeah so so like she was supposed to dog contest winner and he's like this egotistical dog and um and the mutt the main character mutt was like no i've always loved her since since the day she moved next door to me and that's like the entire plot of her like and also him not wanting to get neutered so it's like basically like him not wanting to get neutered and also wanting to get with the other the purebred dog and and so the emotional part is that um he went to a trip club
also is my mic okay i realized i've been oh my god i've been peaking this entire time i hope i haven't um because every time i laugh i see it hit red so i'm sorry if i'm peaking right now okay so they went to it okay not really thank god okay they went to a dog strip club and it's basically like like other female dogs it's it's wild it's just it's just a giant dog's fight it's just a dog strip club and it's like wow and then he bumps into a dog that looks like her his crush um he pumps a new dog that looks like his crush and she's like you want to have a good time and then so you know they do it and then in the middle of doing it the crush shows up it was like how could you i you cheated on me i can't believe that she catches him in the act it's like how could you do this to me oh my god and then the mud was like i thought you were at that session with the other dogs like I love that session so I could see you and then and then obviously like um he couldn't get out of his thing because
if you know Tom if you've ever read um Omega Alpha Beta uh fanfix you know why he couldn't do anything
so so he's like i think her name was so he's like honey no this is what it looks like while he's like still stuck and so so the emotional part was that he ran um he ran back to where honey was with the other male dog and like he was like honey i'm so sorry but like to avoid her getting,
you know, getting on with the other dog.
Because the other dog didn't open his eyes because he's like, he loves himself.
So he's just looking at like himself and everything.
And he's just like in the moment.
So he didn't open his eyes throughout the whole session.
So what the main dog did was that he was, because he's a tiny dog compared to the purebred woman dog.
So he was like one third her size.
So the main dog basically got on top of her and just shimmy down.
So then the purebred male dog didn't bang her, but banged him.
well they were well well the mutt and the purebred female dog had an emotional talk about how much they love each other well he was getting banged by the other male dog so i don't fucking know what you mean when you said it gets really emotional in the middle because because but i watched that scene i am not feeling emotional watching that scene like please stop toky we love bisexual representation they have they have an emotional that sounds so oh yeah yeah it sounds so graphic right imagine watching that because I am trying to spare as many details as possible because it's so much more worse than whatever i'm saying and that's why i i was like no i was like it's so like he's a fucking hidden i knew he was a freak i fucking knew it i was like i'm so disappointed in uh ternikowski i was like no he has suppressed this freak for 20 years like this is what happens never suppress your inner freak guys this is or he or another fix will come never suppress it let it out before it builds up
and it's too late like he let that shit build up for so long and this is what happens he had to let that freak out somehow and that was the build up of all the freak he had inside him for 30 plus years and we let that happen we
We fucking let that happen.
We suppressed him.
They listened to us all.
Never again.
We.
It's like, okay.
Doki is like Dracula full flow right now.
Okay, so thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, so this reminded me of, oh my God, what's his name?
What's the artist's name?
the the guy that did kimba when like his daughter found out he was like a freak too it just it just reminded me of the the kimba artist um the the famous japanese artist that her his daughter found out was also like really freaky because he had like a hidden stash of
like his desk yeah but those who don't know he drew yeah the guy who did astro boy and kimba and that's the yeah and so yeah his daughter after he passed away his daughter was cleaning his desk and everything and they found like they like she found like she was like so surprised she's like oh my gosh what the oh Wait,
I didn't know my dad drew this.
So, yeah, so it was just like drawers and drawers of like unfinished sketches or like practice sketches.
And I think it was like one third of them were like I mean, some of them were naked rats and then snake girls.
Yeah, she washing them up.
And so I'm like never suppress your freak guys or you'll build up.
Never suppress That's the, yeah, if you look, okay, I won't put, I'll post a link to it, but I'm not going to show it.
He was, he was very determined.
All right, let's see.
I won't post, I won't post the, I won't post the, I won't show the pictures, but I'll, I'll post the link to the Reddit.
The, it was the first thing.
So you guys can, yes.
You guys can see Like a Crop picture of the Rat
I am not Clicking that
Why do you I googled it I literally googled Tozuka Furries That's literally what I Googled That's literally what I did Um But yeah no he had like Erotic drawings of like rat girls and snake girls and i don't know how many other animal girls not that bad i don't think she showed everything too that's that's the crazy part she didn't um the daughter didn't even show all the sketches she found she was just like it was just a quick photo and be like oh my gosh look what i found from my dad's drawers um next evening was super chat thank you thank you chat i think the stream is watch maybe game chat have Katie's right after an hour of sorry I think this is a caffeine hitting me hard so I'm like my brain is like zooming through different topics but I hope you will enjoy the one hour of fun facts with Doki we have wasn't that fun chat we had a little fun facts with Doki today extra long
guys learned a lot today anyway so today we are gonna be checking out the uh we're gonna be checking out the dokey jam for those who don't know after an hour we're finally gonna do it for those who don't know what dokey jam was um it was a game jam that uh me and a couple of people organized together um um and handled by one of my mods uh I've delegated this project to one of my mods as their first big project.
They were also the one, the mods that handles the, uh, handles the Minecraft server.
So, um, we have, we have not yet decided who are the winners of the, um, of the dokey jam.
There is like the public vote winners, but there also be, um, it would be decided by me and the team on the final top six winners.
So, I have been giving a list of um i've been giving a list by my um by my mod who handled this project um and um and also you know the the one who also organized the dokey jam of some of the games that they wanted me to check out because like i said there were 200 plus entries um for this dokey jam so obviously i couldn't do all the checks and balances myself because you know i have a very busy schedule so huge looking over all the games and giving me like a selection that they narrowed down for me for me to check out because obviously like I said I can't there's no way I could look through 200 games
myself um man they actually played every single one of your games and uh it's crazy so many talented dragons and uh like a lot you guys are so talented and in my community and It's really crazy to just see you guys make all these cool-ass games for me and all the other dragoons to try.
And we actually put a lot of funding in here.
Because not only do the winners get something, but also every participant, too, will be sent a physical prize.
Well, I won't say prize, but participation reward.
so everyone will be receiving a unique postcard with a foil stamp of my signature I believe I don't know actually I don't know don't mind the foil stamp of the signature I don't know if that's true I don't know if they're doing that or not but I know it's I already saw the postcard itself and that's something I asked to have it implemented I wanted to have everyone to like event so you guys all get everyone who participated who filled out the form um no the postcard is done it's done the illustration is done and um gamer subs is uh producing the postcard so that's like an additional i think like an additional 6k that we're putting into just the participation rewards because we're printing out because there's like 200 plus entries so we're sending out a lot of postcards in general i think like it was another like five the six k in it just because like i wanted everyone to have a little something special um um i love something special um as like a little like memories like a little
memory token for participating in the turkey jam and like um like my basically as a as i say thank you for for giving your time um in doing all of this So if you didn't, if you are, if you did participate and you didn't fill in the form to receive the postcard,
just check your emails or like DM the head, DM the head mod for this project.
If you really want to, the alternative, if you didn't want to like give your address to gamer subs, is basically the alternative is that you get like a voucher coupon code for my merch store.
So if you don't want the postcard.
We basically are giving you a voucher coupon for the merch stores that you can spend on like, you know, X amount of money, like a, you know, get like X percent off on on an item.
But I don't remember exactly how much it was.
I'll show the, I think my mod is awake right now, but if mod, if you, if my mod or slash staff, I think staff is a better word.
My staff member is here right now.
If you can give me a watermark version of the postcard, I can show it on stream and show you guys what it looks like for those who are curious about what the exclusive postcard looks like for the Doki Jam.
It's really cute.
It's basically...
Okay, by the way, after this week, I'm going to rest like one to...
I'm going to...
I have a stream on Monday for a sponsor.
I can say it right now.
say I announce it.
It's an Overwatch sponsor on Monday.
So I have an Overwatch sponsor on Monday.
So I'm going to take Sunday off and then do my Overwatch sponsor and then Tuesday off.
And then if my voice is messed up a little, I'm going to take Wednesday off.
So it really depends.
Because like I need to heal.
Like I've been talking too much.
I've been talking a lot this week.
So I'm Because, like, I can't, obviously, like, Monday is a sponsor, so I kind of take that day off.
But, yeah, Monday and Tuesday will definitely be my off days, by the way.
Hmm.
Other than that.
But, yes, whenever you're ready, Steph, just send me the watermark version of Postcard, and I'll show it to...
I'll show it to the Dragoons.
Let's show them what it looks like, the participation reward.
So, yeah.
New shout-out.
Sorry, I'm, like, sucking on some ice right now.
from my camera last day.
You saw it up to the head staff, to the staff that was delegated this project.
They worked really hard on everything.
And organizing all this, especially the participation reward.
And handling all the logistics in Discord.
And also Kino too, for organizing all of this as well and gathering the artists and stuff to do the trailer and the postcard.
You'd show it to them.
Anyway, let's finally check out Doki Jam.
I was giving a list of games.
I don't know how long I'll be checking.
I'll be looking through all these games for.
But I'm doing them randomly.
I was giving the public vote of top 10.
And then a staff list of other games as well to check out.
So I won't be going through like top 10 and then staff list.
I'll be clicking randomly because I want to give everyone like an equal opportunity, their games and stuff so um and i might do future streams of it too you know like maybe like after the jams over i'll do a future stream to check out more games that you guys made for me um if especially guys i heard like a lot of people who couldn't finish your game in time but still really wanted to um update their game in the future so like you know if you guys want to update your game in the future and i haven't checked it out yet like feel free to and then in the future I might do another I will do another stream looking through all the games in the donkey jam So yeah,
because you know, there's so much there's so much content to go through and you guys worked so hard Like you guys had two weeks to create the game Anyway It's time for to actually check it out.
I'm sorry Vaughan watcher skip one hour So it's like it's like a stream starts here like one hour and ten minutes later And if you're like what the fuck happens for one hour and like 40 50 percent of that was me talking about like uh the dog movie like i was so infested in and then and talking about freaky animators all right let's see i remember which tab okay so this is the first random random jokey jam game we're gonna try out it's called It is this one.
Oh, come on.
Show yourself.
Don't be shy.
Come on.
Oh, wait.
Okay, here you go.
I want to make sure I got it correct.
Okay, it's this one.
All right.
So, this is the first game I'm going to try out.
It's called Doki's Most Wanted.
So, it is a self-puzzle game.
I chose this randomly.
I have, like, a bunch of tabs open.
I chose, I just, like, Bam.
Doki's most wanted is a stealth puzzle game where you navigate through a mirrored floors from Mint's Grand Castle.
Avoid the eyes of the wisp as you perform the ultimate heist.
Many obstacles stand in your way, but you got a few tricks up your own sleeves as well.
By the way, I've never touched any of these games before, so it's like first-hand experience.
So, like I said, I don't know what's going to happen.
So, alright.
W-A-S-D-E-R-E.
are in space that's good i don't need to plug in my other keyboard with the arrow keys um the people who made this game mr mac nova tasso yellow leo and zephy all right and screenshot looks really cool i'm i it's so crazy to see like to see like how how like i don't know how intricate all these games look with just two weeks of development like imagine if you guys had more time it's actually crazy like i'm just thinking like oh my god if you guys had more time how much more like polished all of these games could be when it already looks so good in general so i'm really excited uh to check them out all right i downloaded the game already so let me find it i downloaded all of them um so i just gotta extract it real quick jokey's most wanted let's go It might have been,
it may or may not have been a very bad idea to use up most of my voice to talk about fix the movie.
But, you know, in hindsight.
I could have, I could have chose my time more wisely.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hi, Toki.
Surgery went very well.
And I can use my hat too.
While I can't lift anything heavy, I can still study and work on things.
Thank you for the super chat.
chat thank you thank you i'm really glad the surgery went well i'm really happy for you and um i hope you have a good recovery for later okay let me oh my gosh guys okay settings oh no it's on my other monitor give me a sec okay we have our first hurdle today what's the shortcut to move my thing to my other monitor what's the keyboard shortcut i don't remember
Hey, I forgot.
All right, so you're in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
At least you're awake now, right?
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Because I need a note.
Window shift arrow.
Okay, we got it.
The first hurdle.
We did it.
All right.
Okay, sound guy, we need you here.
This is your time to shine sound.
There's a lot of games with very different volumes.
So good luck.
All right.
Out of play.
Sabotage panels and smoking objects by adding them to your Q with E.
Start training reaction with R to distract mince goons.
Order is important.
Sneak your way to get to the exit.
Press space to get a better view of the low.
Okay, I like the little neck stretch.
All right.
My boss lives in a castle, has a fat ass, and heavily guarded by ghosts.
Where are the other?
Oh, there's like other levels.
Oh, there's other levels.
Should have been tuber.
It's a Baku.
She keeps feeding on my dreams.
All right, except a bounty.
Here we go.
I'm ready.
All right.
Oh, wait, did I misread that?
What did it say?
Wait, what did it...
Oh, my God.
Wait, what did it actually say?
this oh wait that's my it's my chatting screen oh my god look there's little dragons dancing there that is oh fat stacks okay I'm sorry it's just it was it was my subconscious okay not you guys can't lie to me when like i swear to god she a lot of her merch is just her her ass sticking out it was like subliminal messaging at that point like what are you talking about on the gamer subs cup is that not a big example you're so right I love I love how like oh it's like it's basically my chatting screen look at that like the little eggs dancing and the chonku is like that's it that's right keep dancing and then the little dragons here like playing poker okay don't keep it or cut the cube with a super chat thank you thank you oh there's a little animation Oh,
it's still kitty.
Oh my god, there's no air holes.
Is she alive?
Oh, she's alive.
Okay, thank god.
I was gonna be like, where are the air holes?
Holy shit.
How did I live through that?
Where the fuck were the air holes?
I like, that's cute.
A little references.
Alright, hacking in.
Boom.
That's right.
Whoa.
in like maybe like something to do with the cactus or do with the cactus oh shit nice i'm in oh shit i gotta hack again give me a sec i'm hacking wait hack oh okay one two all right i'm so smart there you go what okay okay the time i didn't realize the timing for That is crazy.
Oh, fuck.
How did he catch me?
I don't understand.
I was so far.
Okay.
I didn't realize how fast is.
Okay, then this should be the first then.
One.
Two.
I'm so smart.
There you go.
Nice.
Okay, I got the pattern wrong.
Okay.
He has to look away sometime, right?
Yeah, I knew it.
Ha-ha.
Fucking nerd.
All right.
How the fuck do I do this?
Okay, that's the door.
Okay, he doesn't see me, right?
Okay, he saw me.
Alright, I'm gonna say that his fucking friend sucks out of his job.
Okay, we'll walk this way first.
I wanna go...
Alright, that's the door.
But what else do I have to do here?
Okay, what does this do?
I'm bottom.
oh no oh no oh don't i can't believe i'm trapped all right that was very unfortunate i got confused okay i got very confused it's so okay what is this deal oh oh my god that's fucked up
Wait, I can burn a ghost?
Alright, let's do it again.
Oh, shit.
I can't burn them again.
Oh, that poor whisk.
Don't worry.
I can figure this out.
Oh, I can pause this.
Nice.
Okay, wait.
Restart.
They're flammable ghosts.
Oh, my God.
I used ghosts.
Like, what is it?
There's like, um, like those like, there's like paper.
Those ghosts.
paper that can actually hurt ghosts i have enough time for this i do what oh i have to go left i have to go left oh shit okay yeah i use like those seals i want the wrong side i'm a little special i'm just like thinking like i feel like i do this first And then he goes,
fixes him.
And then I do this.
And then I do...
Oh!
Okay, wait.
Wait, I think.
I'm thinking.
Okay, I understand.
I understand now.
Alright.
So what I do is...
Okay, wait.
What I do is this.
this
okay okay and then yeah give me a sec give me a sec I said I'm thinking okay I said I'm thinking and then this okay and now I'm locked in I, I, I, okay, okay, um, oh, okay, then she goes there, and then I do this again, and then I, no!
Okay, okay, I figured it out, I figured, guys, guys, I figured it out.
Through the chain reactions, I have my new hypothesis.
Okay, what I do?
do this.
I do this.
He fixes that.
And then I do this.
And then I do that.
Boom.
And then Boom.
And then he fixes that.
And then I do this.
And I lock him in.
And he goes to baby jail.
And then he fixes this.
And then he's still locked in baby jail.
And then I did it.
Hey guys, thank you for the five gift of ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Look at that.
Stupid wisp.
That's why you help nobody.
That's right.
look at what you did not break in for free okay boom what the fuck boom what did i do wait actually what did i do i don't know hello what oh he caught me like later okay i actually don't know what is this dude oh shit oh shit oh shit Yeah.
Wait, what does that do?
I don't know what I blew up.
Like, what did I blow up?
That?
The door?
What does this do?
Oh, it's that door!
Oh my god, get out of here.
I'm confused.
My brain not computing right now.
Is it that door?
Okay, we'll do this first.
Maybe this.
this.
Boom.
Oh, there they are.
Oh, I did it.
Yeah.
I'm making it.
That's, whoa.
That's stupid.
I'm right in front of you.
It's because he's so big that.
Oh.
I didn't say the chonkun is so big that Wait, wait a minute.
What are you doing?
Oh my god, he is so big.
Oh wait, I could use him as cover.
He's so big that like he can't look down, you know, like like he can't look down because his entire belly is blocking the view.
I was gonna say, traitor?
What are you a fucking mercenary?
You're gonna ditch me for the highest paycheck?
Okay, he's right covered.
Thank God.
He's hired up.
Large, giant man.
Can't see in front of him because his stomach blocks me.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
All right.
He's a double agent.
He's a whiff's goon.
Whatever Mint pays you, I'll pay $1 more.
where do i go oh there she is oh there she is like i said they oh that's a unique mint model because she doesn't have i just noticed they created a unique mint model
hey that one dollar adds up
that that one dollar adds up
Alright, yeah, Western Minto.
Whoa, what happened?
What's over here?
If that's where Mint is, what's over here?
Is this, like, the exit?
Oh, it's a gun.
It's a gun.
Oh, that traps her.
And then...
Alright.
Doki finally playing Metal Gear.
Doki, when are you playing the new Metal Gear Solid?
Don't worry, guys.
I have Metal Gear at home.
Metal Gear at home.
Alright.
Oh, oh shit.
Ha ha, she can't see me.
Stupid.
What does this do?
Oh, shit.
I think she saw me.
I don't know what that does.
What did I blow up?
I don't care.
There you go.
Don't worry.
Oh my god, he's like Totoro.
Look at that.
Me and Totoro.
What?
How did he see me?
Okay.
I can't believe it.
I'll pay you one dollar and one cent more if you cover for me.
Oh yeah, I can extend it.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
Don't worry, I got this.
Now I can see...
God damn it.
Now I can see perfectly...
Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum, Bum.
Make it two cent more.
The art of the idea.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, there you go.
Chomgoon number two.
Yeah, the cents start adding up, okay, guys?
What the fuck?
Okay.
There you go.
All right.
We gotta go here.
Whoa.
All right.
So that's where she is.
I still don't know.
Oh.
Oh, I have to do this later.
Okay.
Actually, I'm gonna try it now and see what it does.
What does it do?
It's just burning.
Why am I burning chains?
Like, I don't know if that is the...
Right temperature for melting point of of chains All right, don't worry Observe makes you warm
Yeah, but I don't think that fire is a melting point.
I feel like I feel like it's gotta be a lot warmer than that What's this?
Well, I'll never know I guess I guess I'll know it's a cigarette.
I guess I'll never know Okay, I'll get past this
There you go.
Here you go.
I'm getting better See that that two scents is adding up.
You guys are providing better cover now Ha all right except for him i might need a fire this this good you were saying it's not my fault you guys give me bad color yeah i'm straight oh my god okay i need water
all right here we go Simon deductor pay you know some orgs do that like some some esport orgs if you can if you're late to like practices and stuff they deduct your pay like every time you're late like and that's what i'm gonna do next chonkoon i'm gonna deduct your pay by five percent no my money the every time every time you're late to anything you get your paycheck deducted like a normal yeah i'm assuming i'm like Does that actually happen in normal nine-to-five?
But you don't pay us.
Hey, hey.
I'm taking one cent away from your pay.
It starts adding up.
Okay.
I'm trying to, like, figure out what this does.
Oh.
Okay.
No!
Oh my god, I'm never going to get out of this area.
Okay.
Chonkoon, please.
Please.
Why?
Why aren't you chonkier?
I demand a doki patch where you make this chonkoon like 50% bigger.
I want him to take up like half this room.
I demand my chonkoon patch.
I demand my doki patch.
Where he's just, he takes up like half the screen.
Like, where is my Doki patch?
I got you.
All right, here we go.
Feed the dragon hood.
The XL patch.
Doki proof my game now.
My first day DLC.
Chong-goons are now 50% bigger.
I want to know what this does, though.
Does she look that way?
Does she even put it out?
She doesn't care.
She...
What does that do?
She didn't even care.
She's like, oh, it'll fix itself.
It'll fix itself eventually.
right?
I don't even know what it did.
It looked really cool though.
I don't know, I'll just do that just for the fun of it.
Okay, I don't know what this does, but I'm gonna do it.
yeah oh oh oh shit oh shit oh hey guys wait where did she go wait where did she go hello hey
guys am I just chilling here oh wait wait what
I should don't know.
Oh, she's supposed to...
Oh!
She's like a witch.
I fucking knew it.
I knew she was a witch.
Alright.
So, basically, I have to lit everything up.
I just have to lit everything up.
So...
I have to lit everything up.
And then, like, destroy the sprinkler system.
I knew it.
She's like the wicked witch of the West.
Where, um...
Where basically, like, water dissolves her.
So I have to lit it all up.
And then free the world of evil.
Don't tell her that.
Look, she's the one that's dissolvable by water.
I don't make the rules.
I'm like Linda, the good witch.
Yeah, it's from Wizard of Oz.
Okay, like...
But will that...
Okay, wait.
Do I just, like, go back then?
Oh my god, like, where...
How do I get home?
That's why she hates water
All right Because I feel like if I do all of that She's just gonna catch me here Yeah I gotta walk back
Okay Gotta follow the chonkul The one I paid 50% more No I mean 1% more Not 50
Okay.
That should work, right?
And then...
Wait, what?
What the fuck happened?
I'm so...
Oh, I have to destroy the sprinklers first.
Oh!
I figured it out.
I'm going to re-check.
It's all natural.
Alright, Chonkun, get over here.
Alright, don't worry.
My hypothesis that I figured out by myself is that I do all the sprinklers.
I do the sprinkler first.
And then, the fire.
Alright, don't do the fire first.
Do the sprinkler.
Do the hypothesis that I constructed.
yeah
all right nice I don't bump it's like Totoro we're like Totoro me and my friend okay suddenly second-guessing my team's decision to make a puzzle game this is a lie we knew all a lie you all knew what was gonna happen all right nice we did it I'm so smart It was truly a Doki-proof game.
Well, the chain is already on fire.
I don't think I can put it on fire twice.
Two.
Three.
That's right.
That's fucking right.
Burn, you witch.
Burn!
What happened?
So I just let her.
What happens?
She's a ghost.
She's not gonna die in a fire.
It'll just go through her.
Goodbye, the wicked witch of the West.
I did it.
I saved everybody.
I'm a hero.
Yeah, she's already dead.
It's not like she can die again.
She's not gonna go to hell, hell.
The double hell.
That's a...
looking great.
That's right.
That's right, man.
Alright, get over here.
We kidnapped you for ransom money.
Where is he?
She in my chest.
Guys, I swear to God she's not dead.
I swear to God, I'm not gonna cut her body parts.
I swear to God, she is very much alive in this bag.
No shot.
that's in the trash bag she was already dead what do you mean she's a ghost oh no i gotta escape oh my god i think this is a hard one because like they are so are you no no guys don't keep proof this right now them 50% bigger.
Not that way.
Where is the exit?
I thought this was the exit.
Where is...
Oh my god.
It was the same room.
Okay.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Now that we know.
God damn it.
That was me.
I got.
I did it, boss.
Yippee, yippee.
I did it.
As I need a yellow paint, please make a dokeyproof version where there's a giant arrow pointing at the exit.
Don't worry, I can wait.
Don't worry.
I can't wait.
I'll play another game while you put a giant yellow.
But just give me this level in the dokey patch.
Dokey, please.
and I want a giant yellow arrow to point me to the other door and then like a sign that says exit here we had one but we didn't want to make the player feel stupid it could just be for me it could be a be like this is the dokey patch just for dokey And then it's just a giant yellow paint arrow to be like,
please go here.
And then the chunk moves be like 50% bigger.
Enable Doki mode.
Patch for Doki's eyes only.
So no cheating, Dragoons.
Do you want normal difficulty or Doki difficulty?
Okay.
all right don't worry i got this okay you do this this oh we're so smart we're gonna do a first try on this area my very first time doing this part all right don't keep that she's invisible uncatchable has a map has a mini map walk through walls and I feel like every Doki Jam game should have a Doki mode.
That should be the rule.
Next Doki Jam, have normal mode and then Doki mode.
I think that would be really fun.
Alright, nice.
I'll put her in my body bag again.
Oh, it's right here.
Okay, I found the door.
yellow paint.
Next theme is like, it's gonna be called yellow paint.
Okay, the door open.
Oh, thank God.
Yeah, God.
No, it's not God mode.
It's toky mode.
Got her in my body bag.
Yay!
I did it!
It only took me 30 minutes.
Yay!
It said dead or alive, okay?
Oh, shit oh never mind it's extra dead
oh my god wait i share my money where the fuck does she get those boobs
return to menu nice
i'm like why does she get to take off her sports bra i don't don't understand.
Or, I think you gave it a super chat.
Thank you.
That was really fun.
I really enjoyed this first game and, like, going, doing all the puzzles and the little... I like the little references to, like, all the all, like, the like, the Easter eggs around, like, me and my friends and stuff.
So, it was a really fun game.
I love it.
Alright.
Next game.
Next meme.
But thank you again for making this game.
It was very, very fun.
I really appreciate it.
All right.
I think I love the, I love the, like, you even made like a little custom mint bottle too, which was really cute.
Next game.
All right.
Which one should we do next?
Which one is this?
Actually, I'm going to look it up.
um all right this is the next game that i will try out and it is called um what is it called actually tunnels hunted what is it tunnels haunted haunted haunted okay uh dokey's back okay it's a little cut up but we're gonna have to deal with that for oh wait no never mind we don't have we can't deal with that because i want you guys to see the credits too and let me fix that real quick um jokies back in the hallway again fight against monsters in this rogue like pinball inspired game by placing pegs with special abilities to block enemies balls attack use combinations of up to 10 different pegs to make a powerful build and go in infinite or just try to beat the boss in stage 19 oh my god that's a lot of stages i hope i get there um if it takes too long we're gonna have to go to the next game because I,
you know, I want to give, I want to be able to look as many games as possible with the limited time I have today.
Just because I don't want to, you know, I don't want to, I don't want to stream my voice too much today.
But here are the people who made the game.
We have a fall, I'm so sorry, I butcher your name.
I'm really bad at pronouncing names.
Tekken, Tekken, and then Micro for the music.
Alright, let's check this out.
I downloaded this game too, so you guys can see what this game looks like.
There is like, there is like Zombie Goon, Vampire Goon, Live Doki Bird Reaction.
Oh, yeah, it's a roguelike.
I love roguelikes, too, so it's going to be fun.
Tag Dragoon doesn't look okay.
Yeah, that's me after I become Patient Zero.
I'm like, don't worry, guys.
I totally didn't get bit.
i'm not hiding any bite wounds guys and i'm like no i'll be like don't you guys you can trust me i'm totally i'm totally uh um i'm totally healthy not patient zero all right it's called tunnels was it tunnels haunted tunnels or is it tunnels haunted Here you go.
Run anyway.
All right, I'm booting it up.
Oh, there's a story.
Okay.
But yeah, sound guys here.
If any of the music or sounds are too loud, just let me know.
All right.
Well, where's the game?
All right, here you go.
All right.
Mine tunnel.
Zero survivability skills.
As always, Doki.
Oh, there's...
Okay.
Ah, yes.
I never forget to bring my most important equipment.
A shotgun and a revolver.
Alright.
Nice.
I'm ready.
Aim bot on.
Like, don't worry about me, Dad.
take care of yourself all right master return a menu just wanted to make sure is it what the settings were wait oh let's go back to the story part stay here dad all right enemies are balls in this game the enemies are represented by balls you have to place pegs on a game area to bounce the ball if the balls fall on the board you will take damage when a ball bounces on a peg the enemy it's representing will take damage.
Okay, drag and drop.
Open, click and drag an item from an inventory slot to a ball.
You can right-click a peg to send him back.
You can't place the pegs too close.
Areas from multiple pegs cannot be colliding.
Set your pegs in a way to stop balls from falling to defeat the enemy.
When you're done adjusting, click start.
Okay.
Skills, what the off?
He is free.
Every type of peg you have has its own skills.
Bounce way of balancing skills or powers that peg okay chain reaction using pegs that have energy progression all right i got this i figured it out close tutorial um
oh i figured it out
okay here and then i assume here okay let's try and then I'll put it here let's see alright I got alright nice I'm doing it drag gob goblin and slant drag good oh I don't need to load it wait can I have more oh wait I should put this here what am I am I fucking doing okay that's that's a very good wait no it's a new movement oh no okay it's new movement okay I still have one okay here we go boom all right nice I still have like 97 okay and then I just do this there we go yeah I'm doing it all right pick one pay bounce amount of direction as well as damage are random every time a ball hits this five percent chance to bounce all balls instead um every 10 times ball bounce off walls deal percentage based damage when it deals a hundred or more total damage every 10 times balls bounce it counts are three all right that's i will just i feel like we should do this one I want this one.
That looks better.
Next room.
Oh my god.
Okay, we put this here.
Okay, we put him here.
And then we put this here.
And then we'll put it here.
This should work.
Okay.
Look at me, girl.
I'm fucking gaming.
Alright.
I'll put this here and then this here.
This should kill him.
All right, you don't need to see live reaction because I'm literally right here right now.
Actually live.
What do you mean?
I'm literally right here.
I am the better live reaction because I'm literally live right now.
Like...
Like, what do you mean?
We can't see the...
You can't see my face right now!
I want to see the live reaction.
Yuki, get out of the way.
I can't see Toki.
It's not the same, Toki.
We want to see the live Toki reaction.
We got the Toki reaction at home.
Oh, it's the Toki blade.
bounce perpendicularly when activating skill this is not live it's pre-recorded slices a tomato slice off of the end the slice bounces around like a ball we'll start to HP if it falls off the ball there can only one slice per knife at okay we can let's grab that that sounds good other Tokyo abuses you don't know that that's just fucking dope She's a Doki from Dokiverse.
We're all the same.
Alright.
Our Doki is nice.
Alright, let's see.
Wait, I think that...
Did I run out of ammo?
What is...
Wait, what is...
okay I can't dream okay we'll do shotgun here and pistol here I'm at so much HP okay nice all right I'll put this guy here and then this here you should die yeah there you go get out of here all right we'll put here and then this is like emergency bounce oh i can put okay i can't put more okay this should be good that's like a lot that's literally so much damage right now okay nice goodbye all right i'll keep doing that i think that this is good
come on come on do more damage god damn it okay 82.
I'll put that here and this here and this here and dad can be here just in case there we go yes I killed you alright we'll put put a shotgun here I got a good combo good combo dokey blade here and then we'll start it off nice easy one shot oh seven don't worry they're they're clearly evil guys they're evil dragons this skill can only be triggered by other pegs when the skill procs another random skill will be triggered if this is the lowest peg on the board when there's a 35 chance okay i don't know
Downs the closest enemy and deal damage.
Damage and buffs go up for every enemy defeated this game.
When an enemy is defeated, while another enemy is live, trigger every other peg skill.
Okay, that seems better.
But she came to our tunnel.
I don't know.
This is...
I understand.
We live here.
Don't worry, guys.
I'm a hero.
I will protect.
I am here.
This is self-defense.
guys.
I say as I do a home invasion, I this is self-defense.
Good point.
Okay, now it's dead.
Every video game mod ever.
Who gave this fucking drag gooplin a gun?
Alright.
I think this is a good start.
Alright, nice.
Alright, I got extra kill there.
Wait, how many rounds do I have to live for?
Guys.
Did anyone know?
Nice.
Stop trespassing in our tunnel.
Alright, every time a ball hits, there's 5% chance.
has to bounce all back.
Okay, we didn't have, we didn't grab this yet, so I'll try it out.
19?
Wait, how many, how many homes have I invaded so far?
Does anyone know?
This is very important.
How many homes have I invaded?
Nine homes so far.
All right, nine homes that I've self, self-defense successfully.
all right nice bounce bounce bounce bounce all right all right that's just like an insta kill here there we go stage 10 we're nine stages away okay i want to i'm gonna put i'll put this wait if i delete this item
I want to delete this Okay Wait, I want to Oh my gosh, how do I put this item From here Wait, how do I I want to move this Oh, right click, oh, right click, okay Because I want to move this Here Okay, and I'll move the trophy Here Actually, the trophy is really good So I'm gonna I'm gonna move this here and then put okay let's see i'll put the trophy oh my god trophies actually really good i'll put this here i'm mathematicizing right now this here and then the blade here don't worry i'm mathematicizing i got this it missed i just created the Oh my god,
what the was it before guys.
What?
It missed everything.
Oh my god.
What did it?
Oh, I basically fucked up my build.
I actually, I fucked it up.
It was actually, oh no.
Oh no.
Oh no, what did I do?
I actually had, I actually had the dream.
build this is so bad i actually fucked it all up oh i missed i forgot the revolver there you go there you go there you go it's fine i messed everything up i'll have another shotgun the shotgun was good i like the shotgun but the risk was calculated but man toky is bad at math i didn't know
yeah maybe
okay nice nice okay one shot simple geometry was not as simple as i expected guys guys i don't think i'm going to make it to stage 19.
i Who would have thought simple geometry was not as simple as I expected.
Oh, no.
This ain't looking so good.
Okay.
I don't think it could fit another.
I'll put this one.
I don't think it could fit another trophy in.
JK.
I don't think I could fit this one in too.
Okay.
if I move it like this oh no okay oh this is bad I can't okay wait I got an idea
okay oh my god it's so close
if I shift everything higher will that fuck me over it let's see but
last time I shift stuff pie.
It was not so good for me.
Alright, let's try.
This goes straight down.
I don't know.
I'm a little worried because this goes all the way down.
And then we'll put that right here.
Surely this will start something.
Okay.
Oh no.
Okay, 16.
We'll put that here.
All right.
That's okay.
I'm hanging by the thread right now.
Just don't go straight down.
All right, keep the dice.
That's good.
Okay.
I think that hits it.
Okay, thank God.
Oh, my God.
It's going so fast.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, that's fine.
This game, yeah.
Um, oh, man.
I don't have room for... Okay, let's see how much space Kroki takes.
Maybe Kroki is tiny.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I don't think I can shift him anywhere.
You're not you're not living here, I guess I think
Okay, yeah, this works this works That just fell straight oh my god
You guys it didn't work it didn't work it fell straight down I believe it my simple geometry wasn't simple I can't believe it who would have thought it wasn't simple at all
all okay sorry I had to tell you because I I got it hmm I got it I got the the post cards so and the sticker i forgot there's also sticker that's why um that's why it was a lot we put additional funding in it so every participant is gonna get a participation uh prize but i just got the i just got the watermark images for those who are wondering what it looks like all right let me grab it real quick i can't believe they weren't it wasn't simple at all i can't believe it
all right let me uh let me save it real quick for us guys all right so you guys get a sticker and a postcard for all your efforts all right here you go so there's everyone that participated if you guys are if you guys check your emails um the staff has sent a email to everyone uh to input your addresses if you guys are okay with having your address be given in the game yourselves to ship your rewards,
your participation rewards.
So it comes with a postcard.
So this is the, with the foil, oh there you go.
So the foil stamp of my autograph.
So this is the Dokey Jam, the first Dokey Jam postcard that you will receive.
And also, you'll also get a Dokey Jam sticker for your participation reward.
So these two are made by the artist who did the trailer.
who did the trailer and the graphics for a doki jam um so um if you are a participant it doesn't matter if you didn't win or not you will receive a participation reward yay as a little memory for uh same thing for a little memory and a gift from me for you know giving your time and making a little game for uh making a little game for all of us and all our dragons um yeah hope you guys look forward to the participation reward yeah all right next game i'm sorry I don't think I can complete it.
But it was really fun.
I really enjoyed the game and the little, like, the roguelike features and the little bouncy part for the chain reaction.
But thank you!
Thank you for developing this!
I really had a great time playing.
I hope somebody gets to level 19 and tell me what's going on in level 19.
But I love the, I really did, like, love the roguelike features in this game.
Alright, next, next game!
all right next game we'll pick this one this will be the next game that we'll try
Toma Doki so uh Doki's got a long summer ahead take advantage of the time to train her gun slinging music and tomato skills over the weekends make sure that Doki's mood stays high for the stronger multiplier and keep track of your calendar for planned events that can influence your stats.
Based on your choices throughout the game, chain reactions will occur, changing the outcome of Doki's story.
All right, and the developers are one that eats you for director programming, Cloud Lime for design, pixel art writing,
for original music sound design all the screenshots are really cute oh I love pixel art oh my god what the fuck happened to me
I like I like crushed up I accidentally like stepped on the butterfly and my entire life changed and now I live in a box I was like spare I'm like Squidward right now spare change please alright it's this uh all right this is a browser game so i play this on the browser all right unity all right let me turn on pro music uh so i believe whoa oh oh you guys are lucky okay give me a sec i got it's oh i's because i had my thing is up so loud okay let me fix my audio i forgot ever since i updated my you never every time you update your graphics drivers um for some reason all the audio fuck's up on obs so you have to like i have to like uh link it again let's see i believe it's what is it on it's not on it should be on what the fuck where is it no it can't be on game oh wait the fuck oh there it is wait where the fuck is music That's weird.
Where's the music tab?
Okay, I'll just put it on game, maybe.
Wait, why is the music?
Why did the music stop today?
Oh, there you go.
What the fuck?
Okay.
You guys can't hear the music right now.
I'm trying to.
I'm figuring this out, guys.
Don't worry.
Where the fuck is my...
Oh, there it is.
Music.
Alright.
Turning it down here.
doki's got a long summer ahead take advantage of the time to train her gunsling oh it's like a train like a pet simulator okay make sure that doki's mood stay high for a stronger multiplayer and keep track of your calendar for plan events that can influence your stats choices throughout the game,
chain reactions will occur, changing the outcome of Joki's story.
Oh, look, there's tomato.
There's a chonkun.
Farm.
I don't know.
What's this?
Okay, tomato.
We'll do a gun.
Stop!
He's dead!
It's like, pew, pew, pew, pew.
My mood... How did that decrease my mood?
That should be, like, plus 10.
okay why did i get sad i don't understand how would i get sad leave him alone he's already dead okay let's 25 back in the tomato farm tomato increased by hey i had time from a hard state of work one increased by 50 Yoki's at a casino.
Let's go gambling.
Come on, Dragoons.
Actually, should I really make a bet?
Yes.
No, save your money like a fucking loser.
Yes, obviously.
Okay, it looks like I need to choose a number.
Only one choice will win.
Boobs.
Maybe one day it'll be boobs, guys.
This is today.
Guys, today it will finally be boobs.
I lost!
What do you mean it's not boobs?
Money decreased by...
Oh my god, I'm so depressed!
Can we rest by playing Marvel Rivals?
Moot increased by four.
I'm so...
Why is it not boobs?
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, pew.
Pew, pew.
Okay, money moved decreased by one.
Hey, the dragon.
Look, Doki's got new merch.
Buy my merch.
Today I'm selling one-of-kind exclusive new main.
Help!
See, she even talks.
Look at that.
If you press a button, she also makes noises.
Do I at least get a cut?
No.
Maybe we can figure that out later.
You'll regret this Doki burn.
Moon increased by two.
Yeah, that's accurate.
I sold mid and I got happier.
sounds right.
Yay!
Five nights at Freddy's.
Put her in and in her.
Joki's watching dad at home.
It's so cute.
I love the graphics.
The graphics are so fucking cute.
There seems to be a dark spot under him.
Dad.
Don't tell me you peed on.
No!
Not the table!
Whoops.
He pedo.
Music increased by two he has that hasn't had he he has only had one accident in the last five years and the accident was like literally two months ago two to three months ago um when i got him back from the dog sitter uh because like the dog sitter overfed him and like and i went to take a shower before i walked him so he he had like he was it was like post dog sitting day Oh,
what's this?
Doki and Mint are at a convention meaning green.
Doki is getting some stream.
Oh, it's the it's a marriage proposal short.
A marriage proposal?
Two marriage proposals?
Huh?
What are you talking about?
You aren't.
Oh, I don't have 50.
Gun 50.
No, nothing.
You'll feel bad.
All right.
Doki, marry me.
What?
Music increased by 40.
Moon increased by one.
Oh, I need to get...
Oh, guys, I don't...
Guys, I'm not making it, guys.
Guys, I think I'm going to be kicked out.
I think I'm going to be homeless.
Do you think I can make 1,209 days, guys?
be a chance that we might become homeless.
Gambling might not be it.
Mint's visiting Dogeki's place.
Dude, this place is a mess.
What do you mean?
It's so clean.
What?
Look, the books are all organized.
Yeah, look at that.
There's nothing on the floor.
You don't even fit in the shells properly, and some of them are sideways.
um that's called aesthetic hire a mate change no change the subject well anyway uh guys we can't afford a mate right now male male snake solid am i right not what it's actually i feel like that's something i would say just to like rage bait all right let's let's go music again
It's time for Doki's retune checkup.
Oh, it's Nimi!
Why are you in...
How did you get in here?
Well, you see, we had concerns about your health.
Get out of my house!
Okay, whoever wrote these lines, it's so accurate to me.
I was like, what are you doing here?
Apologize, resist.
I don't have anything!
I'm so weak!
Apologize.
I, Doki Doki Bird, am so sorry.
Yeah, it's like lore accurate.
Wait, I didn't say that.
Yeah, I was gonna say, what the fuck?
No, oh, it's fine.
Just let me have a little snack as repayment.
I'm feeling really, really sleepy.
Doki has a weird nightmare.
Tomato increased by 50.
Oh my god, I'm so depressed.
Doki's at an FPS tournament.
Thanks to your gun skills.
She's placed.
No!
To Gerard?
Gerard got second?
That's pretty impressive if this was a real tournament.
What the fuck is this bullshit?
Gerard beats me?
That's the worst you can do in this game.
Train harder.
Doki really fell off for real for real oh my I'm so fucking depressed right now yeah no shit I just got I lost a Gerard my gambling put me in this timeline okay tomato is $400 we got increased The Phantom Thieves Revenge performers are having a reunion.
Wow, it's great that all of us are here.
Yep, every last person who performed at the concert.
All of us together here in the game.
Wait a minute.
Are we missing a few?
Are we missing, like, three people?
Uh, there's only a two weeks.
Money increased by plus 250.
Oh no, guys.
Toki's rent is due and Toki's broke.
Hopefully there are.
No!
I'm in the streets.
Why did I gamble on boobs?
I thought today was the boob day.
You know what I was like one day it will be boobs.
I thought today was that day I can't believe it today was not the day
I can't believe it should I went for boobies one day, but not today.
I can't believe it It finally, it wasn't today!
When will it ever be booze?
Oh my god.
That was really fun.
I, um, I have, um, I want to say like for that game, um, I want to say I love the all, I love the writing for that game and the artwork.
It was so cute.
The artwork was really, really cute.
And I definitely love the writing.
It was very Lord Accurate.
I felt like whoever wrote for the game really knew my personality very, really well because I was like making comments.
And then literally the next line was me almost saying that exact line.
So whoever, and the music too.
I think everything came together really well.
And it was so cute.
The little like pet simulator and all the little events and references and stuff.
And I guess like, and there's like definitely replayability.
when it came to like everyone would get like the different endings and um the different endings and um the uh the different scenarios that events and stuff that pops up and you have to like train for specific things to trigger certain events so lots of repealability there very cute work and thank you for participating i really love your game i love all the games honestly they're all really really cute all right next um um all right what which one should be the next game like i said i'm choosing them um the for those who don't know how i'm choosing these games for review i was giving two lists the top 10 um that was that i was publicly rated and also like um the staff um a list that staff recommended to try out so i was given a list two lists and i'm just picking them by random guys so um just trying my best to give everyone an equal chance to be seen on today's stream also before i do the next game i am going to grab water because my throat needs water i'll be right back guys
my amazon order just came too i got i ordered a laundry basket because i never got i figured it's finally time to have a to have like a basket to put my laundry and so just putting it in the uh so just putting it in the washer well and some cough drops so it's laundry basket and cough drops no i never had a laundry basket i thought i decided maybe it was time to invest in one
where i put my clothes once they dry in the dryer until and it's just uh i just never need I was like, maybe I should have a laundry basket.
I'm becoming adult very slowly.
It's getting there.
All right, what is this one?
All right, next game.
Let's see.
This is the next game.
It's Colin.
Jokey birds, time, turmoil.
Side-scrolling twin stick shooter where you can chain explosions made for the dokey jam.
A and D to move.
W or space.
Okay, A and D to jump.
S to drop.
Left click to shoot.
Right click to throw bombs.
One, two, three to swap guns.
And the credits are Brood Lees for programming.
Match box mocks for art and writing.
And Boner for the...
great name for the billboard art and tiny bit of writing um so i downloaded this one too so let me pull that up time turmoil bum bum bum bum oh wait sorry that time turmoil where is it there it is run all right bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum bum
I hope all the sound has been okay so far.
I don't want it to be too loud so you can still hear me.
All right.
Let's see.
There's me throwing a bomb.
Boom!
I'm like, I did it.
There's the time.
I'm like, what the fuck is this?
Huh?
I'm touching grass which is a little unrealistic but okay poof oh I was transported here okay that makes it more realistic I wouldn't do that consensually where am I plop huh look at the date I went back in time by a whole week I went back in time by a whole week Doki steals Chinese take Wait,
why?
Joki puts hair dye in someone's shampoo.
Joki places firecracker in toilet.
Oh my god, I'm a menace.
That's right.
Joki puts hot sauce in tea pot.
Oh, that did something.
And look at the time.
I'm back to the present.
Oh my god, he's dead.
Oh yeah, that's cute.
but the time machine is sparking now i think i broke it okay oh i can double jump is that part platform okay i was gonna say press s to drop okay boom right click to throw bomb and shoot it to activate okay boom boom okay there's the chain reaction oh this is like such a cute game look at him oh my god good boy that's right my genetically engineered take dog good boy i knew that government funds were spent on something good like whoa try boosting yourself an explosion uh that i knew he was indestructible guys i just want to show Where your tax dollars went.
I'm petting him.
Try to boost yourself while running in Dexter to boost.
I didn't do that.
But, like, I think that's fine.
The Wild West.
Oh, it's a dragon.
Eh.
What's on your face?
Where did you find a marker?
You've been a blind rage all week after someone stole your...
I wish I could show you.
Wait.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
I'll show you guys what he looks like.
He's a very angry egg.
You could tell he's very angry.
Just...
You've been a blind rage all week after someone stole your Chinese food?
Who could do such a thing?
Oh my...
Oh, wait.
I did it.
Oh, shit.
Ah, my dad is just there witnessing my crimes.
Nice dad.
Let's go.
Who would do that?
Another dragon.
Oh, shit.
Wait, I was going to show you guys what he looks like.
Oh, my God.
Are you going to rob someone?
Wait, no.
This is a fake.
Wait, is that actually a dragon?
Why are you blue?
Is this a whisper gun?
and what yeah what are you wearing why exactly why are you blue i wasn't always like this i felt pressured by the toxic beauty standards of society everywhere i went there were billboards and ads of beautiful multicolored creatures and i just wanted to be purple but then the dye i went missing who could do such a thing because I didn't steal it not me that was written there I don't know if you guys saw that but there's a little bit of a text glitch I had to buy a new one but the one I originally purchased was out of stock the color was the closest a purple I could get and look at me I'm ruined I wear this blue blah blah blah blah to hide my shame of being blue.
We can fix this.
You'll buy another hair dye with your money.
No, it's too late.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
Bob.
I know what to do.
I'll just kill him.
Guys, I know what to do to solve this.
I'll just put him out of his misery of being a blue.
Guys, don't worry.
Violence is always the ass.
Oh shit!
Oh my god, he's got a gun!
Holy shit!
What a fuck is that dragoon a gun!
Oh my god, that's fucking crazy!
Pop, pop!
Oh my god.
Oh, I don't have another...
There we go.
Not so armed and dangerous.
No lies were lost in Dokiland.
Alright, there we go, nice.
Oh, hey, Doobie.
Oh, shit.
Now it's my train.
Hey, Doobie.
What do I get?
Click the price tag to purchase.
Thanks, you.
What?
I just wanted...
Oh, shit, the dokey knife.
Why nine?
Wait, how much money do I have?
200.
Bomb damage.
Oh, I'll grab.
Wait, how do I buy this?
Okay.
Nice.
Okay, bomb radius.
I like the...
Okay, I feel like piercing would be good.
I'll buy the piercing.
Alright, nice.
Goodbye, dude.
Oh, shit.
That was my train.
Okay, this is the new goon.
Oh, hey, Doki.
A dragoon, uh, what's with the armor?
It's a long story.
I won't waste your time explaining.
No, I want to hear.
If you insist, it all started with my passion for cooking.
And my hero, Chef Tim, offered me an opportunity.
to cook for him.
To prove my passion.
And if I succeeded, he would give me a job at Vite Rotman, a real dream come true.
I was going to make a midoscious, stavious, gelatinous noodle stew with a breast of a cow topped with mentha spiccata.
It's just beef carrot stew.
And the core ingredient was hot sauce.
But on a day that was private jet landed in my area.
My hot sauce was missing.
Who could do such a thing, dragoons?
I guess we'll never find out.
I made a subparamil.
And for that, my hero, Chef Tim, verbally abused me.
It was a pain like no other.
I started therapy, art therapy, group therapy physical therapy accelerated experimental dynamic psychotherapy and the only thing that stopped my pain was to shut myself off from the rest of the world i swore i never let anyone hurt me again i put on this armor to symbolize this no that's horrible I'm... What the fuck did I do?
Yeah, what?
What?
No reason.
This just...
This game just needs more enemy.
The plus 999 defense.
Alright, don't wear a piercing.
Look at that.
Oh my god, wait.
That's right.
That defense is doing nothing for you.
That's God...
Oh my god.
He explode.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Okay, this is a lot of shit right now Oh my guys, this is bad.
This is this is very bad.
This is very I'm like stuck in the loop right now
I'm oh my god, it's the guns.
It's actually the guns.
It's oh My god the RNG you guys just fought in front of me.
It's not fair holy shit okay you guys like spawn in front of me that's not fair that's not fair at all oh my god please please dad you're supposed to give me hp okay at least i have piercing thank god boop and weep long dragon not you too all right this is what he looks like oh my god you're a nerd?
Of course, Longoon is a nerd.
Not you too.
What happened to you?
What happened to me?
He's a wizard.
I'm a what?
I became my strongest self after someone left their firecracker in my toilet.
It exploded as I softly placed my behind on the toilet seat.
I was sent flying through a wall.
And through that wall, I discovered a secret room where a gnome was secretly living under my roof.
I had the most powerful, wonderful conversation with that gnome.
We talked about the stars and planets and our favorite constellation.
It was romantic.
to die by sunfall they gave me a magic staff it made me promise to learn everything i could about arcane everything that they could not that they could not with their limited time oh my god he got gnomed and now you're a wizard right and you're living your best doom yaoi longgood is in a doom yaoi storyline on you live your hey it could be Jury guys I know he don't want to hurt me right oh dokey I'm not the dragon I once was I have felt the power of the staff and my story has only just begun I can see clearly now that my destiny is to rule over all now that I've had the taste of true power I know it is my destiny to rule the world anything and everything in my path.
Oh, no.
Who could do such a thing, guys?
We gotta find the menace who keeps doing all these things to the dragons.
Holy shit!
Oh, I'm dead.
I am so dead.
Oh, my.
I'm not.
I don't think I'm living this, guys.
Oh, oh, my God.
This is not looking good.
for the story of Doki Bird.
Dad, please.
I really, please.
Please.
Oh, my God.
Please stop spawning in front of me.
No, no.
Not the rage.
Anything but the rage.
How do I...
Not the magic.
Oh, my God.
That's not fair.
He spawned in front of me.
Hmm.
Okay.
Oh, now you find me heels, Dad.
That's fine.
It's fine.
Nice.
We did it.
There's heels now.
Oh, we're so healthy.
We're so healthy.
Oh, my God.
Thank God.
Dad found heels.
There we go.
Chain reaction.
Pew, pew, pew.
Pop, pop.
Pew, pew.
Pew, pew, pew, pew, pew, just cue pewing.
That's fucking right.
There we go.
We're doing it.
We're figuring out the rhythm.
Oh my god.
There's two guns.
There's two goons.
There's two dudes.
How the fuck do I dodge that?
Okay, that's bullshit.
Alright.
GG's no heals.
mind you heard me he actually heard me he actually is like excuse me what did you say
there you go i got heals gg is supportive all right nice hello doobie i do be needing some upgrades all right i want okay i need the joki
Um, what else can I?
And I can't afford anything else.
Let's go.
I got the Joki 99.
Oh, Min.
I'm so glad I found you.
Wait, what's wrong with Min?
Where's your eyes?
It's been chaos up there.
All the dragoons have been thirsty for blood.
Min?
Oh, shit!
What the fuck?
Oh, no, not Toho.
Not, of course, Mitsa's Toho's.
God damn Toho.
A fucking course.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, this is strong as hell.
Not gonna lie.
She does, like, nothing.
She's so weak.
Oh, I forgot I have, like, a bomb.
A Drifter.
I've just been, like, 9-9 in.
Okay.
No.
Oh, no.
No, I said no.
Okay, it's okay.
It's okay.
Oh, no, man.
Everything is fine.
There you go.
Oh, my God.
What up?
This is intense.
This is actually pretty intense right now.
Oh, my God.
I can't stash, man.
You know that.
Okay, at least like...
Her body doesn't have a hitbox.
That's good.
Yeah, I killed her!
Oh, there it is.
She has brain worms.
Oh, she has brain worms.
Holy shit, that was like crazy.
We have a fight.
That goes hard.
I didn't unlock Dash yet, mid.
That's cheating.
First try.
Let's go.
I love this fight so much.
Thank you for the super chat.
Wait.
Um, Sumi, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, I saw an Akasupa earlier, too.
Let me say.
Oh, Shady, thank you, the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Oh, no.
Ministers, see, too.
Are you okay?
Not really.
I feel like I got my ass kicked.
Why am I on the floor?
You don't remember what happened?
You're attacking me, so I have to kick your ass.
What?
No, I would never let you...
I would never kick your ass first.
Remember anything you did a week ago?
Finally, the last I remember is eating at a restaurant when one of your eight goons in a fair range ran in and scattered bugs everywhere.
Oh, but this man with a massive head yelling at the dragon for stealing the bugs you're experimenting on.
I did see a bug fall out of your ear.
A bug in my ear?
I think I'm gonna be sick.
You think it was a mind control bug?
Oh, I'm sorry.
You would never got infested with a mind-controlling bug if an egg dragon didn't attack the restaurant with bugs if I hadn't gone back in time and not do stole a Chinese take up.
I wonder who could have sold a Chinese take up.
Sorry, it's like written over here with invisible ink that only I could read.
I'm sorry, guys.
Like, it's like, they like dokey proof the game.
So I really don't know who would do such a thing, guys.
Oh, it's all right.
Wait, you went back in time?
uh yeah i was breaking into some rich guy safe so i could sell his stuff to the black market turns out it was time traveling device and i accidentally went back in time how far back did you travel only a week i thought it'd be funny to put some pranks when i came back all the pranks i've done have had some sort of horrible domino effect but this is unrelated to what happened to I did different pranks,
Mint.
For sure.
Or some kind of chain reaction.
But, um, yeah, a chain reaction.
Do you still have the device?
I do, but I think it's broken.
Theme drop.
You need to find something really smart to fix it.
You're right.
But, hmm.
Maple E.
Michael Reeves.
He's in.
inventor.
Michael Lee.
Lily's boyfriend?
The Michael Reeves?
The flesh tuber?
Is that where he's doing what he's doing instead of uploading on YouTube?
Sorry, Lily's abused boyfriend.
Man, Time's machine has gone.
to be out of his expertise i did hear about invent oh who's michael reese michael reese is like an inventor that makes the the inventions where people always go like why he he made a all right what are some of his craziest inventions that he's made he's made a um um a rumba that like yells yells profess like yells at you oh yeah he did a he invent yeah he made a screaming rumba oh yeah and then he made a base baby with laser eyes too um and the pain box as well he's made a lot of stuff i did hear about the inventors party happening in the city maybe someone there could help you i've got to get there as soon as possible do you know where it is It's right down the street.
Thank you so much, Mint.
I'll see you later.
Good luck.
Alright.
Hello, Duby.
I do be needing upgrades again.
Alright.
I'll grab.
I don't feel like I need health.
Maybe, like, faster bomb charge.
For sure.
And then flat bomb radius.
Alright, here you go.
What the?
Oh, shit.
It's...
the rabbits this is what happened ah cray violence what happened to you i stuffed you in the locker not you too what happened ah me and may may were having a tea party but someone put hot sauce in the tea pot there wasn't any milk in the house so we ran outside searching for some we were desperate may may and bow bow we found a half empty bag of milk next to nuclear waste plant and started to mutate rapidly after we drank it.
Why would you drink milk you found next to a nuclear waste plant?
I don't know, Doki, why did you stuff us in a locker and never came back?
Now, close to your house as a nuclear waste plant?
The milk may have been radioactive.
Wait, where's Mei Mei?
Ah, she grew wings and flew away.
Buffet become uncontrollable.
Blood-firsty creatures.
So I'm going to eat you now.
Oh my god.
Why are there so many of you?
Oh wait.
Is this Metrovania?
It sounds like Metrovania.
My copyright free.
Metrovania.
We're gonna have a bad time.
Why does it
Oh shit!
Oh megalovania, sorry, megalovania.
Oh my god, it's...
It's Mei Mei and Bao Bao!
Yeah, sorry, megalovania.
Holy shit.
Oh my god, please!
I'm sorry!
I'll come back!
Bring you back!
I'm so sorry!
It's like the...
It's like Jesse from Toy Story 2.
Like, I'm so sorry!
I'll play with you again!
This is my Megalovania.
Oh shit, I forgot my R99.
Well, well, well.
Wait, Nimi, what the fuck happened to you?
If it isn't, a dokey braid.
Nimi!
You look different!
She looks goffy.
I've changed, Doki Bird, after someone snuck purple hair dye into my shampoo.
Who could do such a thing?
Oh my god, Nimi!
I didn't even notice.
I love the new hair color.
Purple looks so good on you.
Why is she herpa?
I've embraced an emo lifestyle, Doki.
And my name isn't Neemie Nightmare anymore.
It's Nightmare, Nightmare, like Nightmare Moon.
I'm a deaf metal now.
You could say I'm an artist.
I severely damaged my vocal cords trying to vocal fry.
But I like the pain.
I take hot showers every day to practice burning in hell.
Why didn't you draw your hair back?
color out dokey it won't come out my old hair color is dead and gone nightmare nightmare has purple hair and i don't eat nightmares anymore nightmare square i am the nightmare oh my god where's my what the why is there two of you oh my god this is so bad dad please dad please i that I that please I I need I think dig for HP dig for HP I don't need more bombs I please I I don't need more bombs oh no it's nightmare oh my god guys okay it's nightmare with a gun oh god oh my gosh she's so tanky a clutch okay maybe we got upgrade dad actually oh it's chocolate rain that's like this this music the chords are so familiar it's chocolate rain oh my god you're right i was like why do i feel like i've i never even
Chocolate-free, guys.
Okay, we'll get more health.
I feel like...
Okay, we'll try the shotgun and see how it goes.
Okay, let's get this here.
Alright.
There you go.
Dad, I want to try the shotgun.
There's Lily.
There's Lily P2.
Oh.
Oh, is that toky bird I see?
Yeah, you're...
Oh, my God.
I don't know why I said that.
How'd you get so buff, Lily?
Oh, well, it all started a week ago.
But I found the fortune cookie on the sidewalk while walking 10 feet.
Oh, shit.
I think I dropped one while running away with my not-soil and Chinese food that I legally paid for.
Is that dad up there?
Wait, you ate a fortune cookie you found on the floor?
that's nasty I just opened a cookie to read my fortune my fortune red you're so frown and weak that even a bug squish you we are I was offended honestly but mostly hurt and so I train obsessively every day from dawn till dusk I box with a boxing robot my boyfriend made then at the end of every night I beat my boy
wait can someone screenshot this I would have send this to Lily.
Someone screenshot this and I want to send this to Lily.
Wait, actually, no.
No, you don't need a screenshot.
I'll pause it in the pod after the stream ends and I'm sending over to her.
You guys don't need a screenshot.
I'll pause it in this pod and I'll screenshot it myself and then send it to her.
I need to get stronger, clicker.
I started taking steroids wow it took so many steroids oh god i love the writing this is crazy the local pharmacist wouldn't give me steroids anymore i broke it to people's homes and looked through their medicine cabinets looking for more did you find some i found a bottle labeled steroids the pills look completely different but i just assumed they were a different brand my mood started to change looked more into it and turns out these weren't steroids.
They were angry pills.
Alright, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
Dad is being a brat right now.
Dad.
That's right.
He's fine.
What makes the pills angry?
He got into the angry pills too.
I've been sent into a fit of rage, Doki.
Now I have to beat you up, just like my boyfriend.
You don't seem angry.
No, I'm just good at hiding my emotions.
But that's really incensed that you'd assume that I'm not angry just because you can't see it.
You've really done it now.
I'm going to skin you alive.
Lily peach you more like Lily Macho.
Look at thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
The chocolate rain?
Okay.
Oh wait, here.
Thank God.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Oh, okay, wait, wait.
I want to try the shotgun actually.
Boom.
Honestly, I think...
I think the...
Yeah, the Doki 99 is the strongest so far.
Yeah, I like the Doki 99 the most out of all of it.
It's the strongest gun.
It's just go brrrr.
Eat.
I like, I love the writing.
The writing, props to the writer.
The writer, the writer knows this shit.
All right, it's the ghost of future, I guess.
The Christmas ghost of future.
Doki, have you been streaming regular?
regularly oh my god it's my manager it's so good is it after being tortured by your dragons what what did they do to you one of your dragons that stumbled upon a staff of the arcane it became used it became using his newfound powers for evil abusing his powers your dragons put chains around my wrists and ankles and locked me in the dungeon for years when you've been locked in dungeon for less than a week?
Let me continue with the story and I'm lying for dramatic effect.
The dragon will stop by my cell regularly to give me wedgies.
I was beyond mortified.
I noticed a twig in the corner of my dusty cell and out of desperation started training quietly behind bars, hoping that one day I could use the twig to cast a spell.
I'm here for justice after what your dragoons have done, Tommy.
Mr. Man, I can explain.
Oh, no.
No, please.
Please, I don't want to do my task list for today.
I...
Please let me ghost you.
I just wanted this associate for one more hour.
Mr. Manager.
Wait.
Please let me play Dynasty Warriors one more time on stream.
Let me kill my channel one more day.
War manager, repent.
Have you repented for your sins yet guys?
What's this?
Ow shit.
I heard.
It's okay.
I'm not actually killing them.
They're just respawning, guys.
Oh, chocolate brain.
Man, if only all SMGs do not require.
Okay, I... I just... Please, dad, please.
Stick for it.
Oh my god.
Liz, I don't need bombs!
I'm 1 HP!
I'm 1... No!
Wait, do I live?
Oh my god, I live.
Okay.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
This is, yeah.
Thank you for the HP.
Okay.
Oh, two eight.
Yes.
Okay.
Good timing.
Very good timing.
I really appreciate that.
Okay, I maxed out.
I don't think I'm gonna use shotgun.
I feel like the shotgun is, uh, okay, I guess I have enough money for the shotgun.
typical dad behavior the inventor's party should be nearby hey do you know where the inventor's party is who's this guy where is it you're talking tom my oh she Thomas Edison how are you alive I resurrected myself you resurrected oh my god it's my oh she Thomas Edison
resurrected yourself while dead all right well technically no i just want to take credit for this fabulous new resurrection technology that's my own sheep right there everyone who existed between 1800 and 1888 is once again alive how exciting the only part i'm excited about is having to coexist with that tesla that scummy tesla nonetheless i've already accomplished a great deal after returning the land of the living.
I am into ways that make humans, animals, and everyone in between considerably more irritable and susceptible to violence.
No wonder everyone has been attacking me.
Classic, Thomas.
Who resurrected you anyway?
After I rose gracefully from my slumber, this annoyingly cheerful scientist was celebrating that I had awoken.
He kept rambling about how his doctor prescribed him angry pills due to the self-fulfilling nature of how naturally joyful jolly he is, but how recently a side effect of his medication were big muscles and an even bigger brain.
That scientist must have taken the steroids that someone else swapped.
And you're some sort of yellow humanoid avian?
What are you?
Some kind of... No, I'm Dokeybird, and it's just a skin suit.
Now that I think about it, that name sounds familiar.
Oh, have you heard of me did he receive all the fan mail i wrote to him of my oshi yes and it's quite unfortunate what i have said i'll send a clip of you talking about me you were shipping me with that's not true it was called doomed yowie it's not technically it's not really a ship it's like a passion to be frank that clip ruined my life the mere idea of me being with that creature Quite literally gave my father a heart attack.
Of course not.
He was simply startled because I'm lovingly engaged to Henry.
To be fair, I'm like, it's the 1800s.
Like, it's a time.
It's a period where, you know.
To the riot to the start.
I mean, like, it was the 1800s.
I would assume he was.
like
something about mutated rabbits an extremely muscular pink hair lady emo nurse and vengeful warlock my father had to be transferred from our hospital in New Jersey to a hospital in New York I stayed in New York to take care of my father and none other than Nikola Tesla was living that area no matter my frivolous attempts at avoiding him I encountered him in coffee shops on daily walks at the hairdresser,
eating tacos at the zoo because I needed to purchase an elephant for one of my experiments in toilet sauce.
Teltzla came to believe that I was stalking him out of love.
The delusional man eventually confessed his love for me.
Nikola Tesla is in love with you?
Of course he is.
Oh, that's true.
Who isn't in love with Thomas Edison?
But I can't stand that right.
I feel like I'm in a different game now.
I don't think I'm in the same game anymore.
I think like we had a genre swap.
I'm sorry that Tesla is bothering you, but I need your help.
I need a fix this time machine.
Oh, please, I can only blame you, Toki bird.
They made this in two weeks.
For this, I feel like this game does not feel, I feel like they spent so much.
Did you guys sleep while making this game?
Like, for this terrible inconvenience.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
I'm actually just playing soap song now.
Holy shit.
Oh, my God.
I gotta kill my oh, she.
Okay, you got this Sometimes you gotta kill what you love For the greater good Oh shit.
Oh shit.
Yeah, I'm playing.
Yeah, don't all this is bad.
Please jump.
Please jump Oh no, no Does he reset?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Maoshi is very very strong.
My oh my god oh i am actually playing i'm i'm actually playing silk song right now this is silk song oh god oh i did not mean it
oh my god please go nope nope nope how do i dodge this how do i dodge this.
Help!
Dad, please, I really, please, please!
Oh my!
Oh my god, okay.
Guys, I don't think I'm winning this.
I think my Oshi's gonna win.
Oh my god.
What is this level?
holy shit okay wait the music is very loud there you go I had to you guys the music was very loud
oh god okay I need like more range okay this is good this is not good
there you go please dad please please please oh
no oh come on 17 yeah no I had to kill my you mustn't continue with this violence it isn't right what isn't right is you is you coming here i told you i am i'm sorry okay um what isn't right is you coming here i told you i'm in love with henry ford
if Henry really loved you he'd be here but I'm the one who's here again
can't you see it right now
because I did it I got the true ending I got
oh my god I did it I got the true ending chat I did it.
True ending.
Oh my god.
Absolute cinema.
Why is he cheeked up?
It's motherfucking Nikola Tesla.
I did not expect.
It was like a I felt like I was playing a different game when Thomas Edison came up it was just like it was a different game the surprise was yowie what a plot twist that was that was incredible i did not expect even dad was like playing again what a journey give me a sec i i need to give dad
all right all right i had to give dad some extra extra extra munchies oh my god that that's pretty i think the most incredible thing about this game is the fact that um this was made in two weeks uh wonderful game really great writing i love the writing so much um i love the too um what a plot twist you had so many references to like my everything like a lot of the stuff i done on stream like even the fact that thomas edison my oh she like you actually knew who my oh she is like that's it yeah the story just kept escalating look at thank you for the akasupa they thank you
yellow pen pick like incredible plot twist um the fact that this team made this in two weeks was insane like you guys i hope you guys got good rest right after but thank you again what a wonderful game love the art love the writing mechanics were really fun with the toho and um gave me some toho and silk song too um great game honestly what a wonderful game all right all right Time for the next game.
Next game.
Hmm.
Alright.
What do we play next?
Let's see.
We will try.
I forgot which one to try next.
Oh, there's so many wonderful games.
Alright.
I'm gonna try the...
Okay, I'm gonna make sure this is...
the correct one let me look up let me look it up real quick um but because um the last game we played was rank one or actually placed first in the in the um people's votes so the dragon's votes so that was a wonderful game i can see why it placed first place um but yeah really great game i'm gonna try and play second and third third place games and then we'll do we'll do another um we'll do another stream uh next week um for more doki jam games because you guys all did amazing likes i want to go through as many as i i didn't help that i went through like one hour of like um one hour of doki fun facts too i mean that didn't help but yeah i would love i really want to play more of the games that you guys made so next week i'll play uh more doki jam games and i won't get distracted this time and i do need to rest my voice so i'll play rank two and rank three uh next i'm gonna make sure that it is the right one though like i said i made it random i like chose them randomly from the list
they were giving me so i don't know if the tabs i have are the correct like the correct rankings um oh i did already played oh tomah tomahjoki was rank three okay so i'll play rank two and then we'll call it for today um i'll be picking the so joki's choice um um will be decided i don't know when i'll decide like my personal choices um but it'll be me and my staff will look through all the ratings and the list of games together and choose like the final the final winners um but yes thank you again um i really appreciate all the hard work all the dragoons did it's been it's such a fun game it's honestly all your games have been incredibly fun so thank you guys i really really appreciate it you guys are so fucking creative all right uh bum bum bum all right rank two i download is this download a bit i download this one yeah i did so this is rank two rank two is
one bullet dokey bird so w-a-sd right click aim mode left click fire tab switch between dokey and mint left click push objects reset level walk mouse wheel up is sensitivity um you might have noticed this complicated sounding option one of the uh but you're the thing that ties nudge and n can result in wildly unpredictable changes after four or five bounces we wound up implementing two systems to help to play with this reactive mode automatically lower the sensitivity the number of bounces in the predicted path allows you to adjust the sensitivity of leisure with your mouse wheel if okay we'll do reactive mode first all right so the team is frail with the sprites uh geobah with the programming music sound effects next to you in level design and story orca zone with illustration and ui design and rice with programming sprites and level design all the sprites are so cute guys oh my god you guys can recognize like um a couple of your fellow dragons here in the team uh all the um some of
the regulars too uh that's cute and frell i've worked with frell so many times in many different projects so it's really good to see all guys coming together for this uh all right what's this stumped don't worry we prepared solutions for all levels and that nice what if i just watch this video i'll be like guys i'm doing it
i'm guys i'm i'm playing my game i'm that was that wow oh my god I'm doing it, guys.
Actually, dokey-proofed.
All right.
Maybe in the next theme, I'll be like, dokey mode.
Every game has to have a dokey patch.
A dokey mode.
All right.
Let's see.
Turn down.
We're in your head.
We knew you wanted dokey- turn the music down a little bit just in case because like it looks like it's really loud on my obs all right play hey dragons i'm back from vacation did you miss me wait what happened here where is everybody what's this a note hey dokey i need your dragons for a special project i'll them back later.
See ya.
Huh?
You can take my dragoons.
I need them for my projects.
Whoever you are, you made a mistake.
Alright.
Are you sure this is a place?
Yeah.
I put trackers on some of my dragoons and they all lead here.
Oh my other crookie!
Oh, look at my crosshair.
It's a bullet.
You have trackers on your dragoons?
Don't worry about it.
I'm going to take a closer look at those guards.
It looks like they're robots in...
Robots in disguise.
What kind of robots?
They look kind of like dragoons.
Aw.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Were you hoping for sexy robot women?
Um, I'm hoping for sexy robot women.
No.
yes anyway damn there's a lot of them good thing I brought uh-oh I don't like that uh-oh I forgot my extra ammo I'm gonna have to make every shot count what's that phrase one shot like oh man what's that what's that phrase don't hear don't worry I got this I'm a gamer watch and learn.
Alright, W-A-S-D.
Oh, I can move.
One shot, one kill.
Oh, okay.
Pew pew.
Just like the real Doki.
Easy, as long as I don't get too close.
I can take him out with one shot.
Remember, Doki, this is a sneaking mission.
What?
Never mind.
Who needs to sneak when I can kill all witnesses?
These are all the bossy Xboxes in the way.
Maybe you can try hiding in one of them.
Why would I do that?
Stealth be exactly...
Stealth is optional.
Forget it.
Wait, I have an idea.
Give me a sec.
Look, if I turn invisible, the guards can't see me.
I'll move things around to help you line up your shots.
shot can do before they notice and go on alert so be ready okay how do i okay how much can i move
bing bing bong
oh Patrick here easy bing sing what's that helpful for me We make a pretty good team, don't we?
You push some boxes.
Yeah, I could do that, too.
A minute, you could have made that shot without me.
Okay, fine.
I guess maybe we do.
Okay, I would have still, I would have denied it.
Just a rage baiter.
Hmm, they aren't lined up like last time.
It's fine.
See that metal drum?
I can bounce my bullet out of it.
if you move it over a little.
That doesn't even make sense.
Oh, yeah?
Try it.
You'll see.
Alright.
Wait.
Oh.
Okay, I have to...
I have to move this.
Bong!
Oh, there you go.
Yay!
See?
No problem.
I guess I'm the brains of this team, huh?
Huh?
What does that mean?
Doki bird?
Wait, that's a real dragon over there.
What is he doing?
He shouldn't be working for anyone, but exactly!
Trader!
Watch out for those barrels, Doki.
They look kind of dangerous.
How dare you?
That's what you get.
How dare you walk for any work?
That's right.
No mercy for treason.
For that poor dragon.
Isn't your job to make sure they're safe?
He was working for the other side.
It was treason.
How dare you?
I can't believe he would do such a thing.
He was a spy.
There we go.
Oh wait, never mind.
I can't believe that.
Okay.
Alright, how do we do this?
Oh!
There you go.
That should... right?
There.
Oh, whoops.
Alright.
There.
Don't worry, I got this.
I'll fix this.
By doing the same thing.
Okay, don't worry, I got this.
All right, this time.
There you go.
Okay, I didn't see that.
Don't worry.
I got this by doing a different thing.
Oh, shit.
Okay, don't worry.
Eventually, something will change.
Wait, okay.
Wait, how do I...
Wait, actually, how do I...
I'm doing a different save.
Don't worry, this time, it will be different.
It will...
There we go.
Alright.
Wait, I figured it out.
Bing.
I don't know what...
Something different will happen.
I swear to God.
There we go.
I did...
Oh.
Okay, wait.
I figured it out.
Don't worry.
What the fuck?
It said it hit him.
okay I figured it out
as long as I don't accidentally kill him it should be fine it's the little things
there you go we did it
I took the I knew you'd come save look see I saved his life he doesn't know the he doesn't know that he died Seven times in this previous live.
Please, the others are still captured.
First try.
He doesn't know.
Won't hurt him.
What a coward.
I have more questions for him.
You made that so much harder.
Look, there's another dragon.
With all those barrows.
I bet your bullets gonna bounce around like crazy.
Don't worry, man.
I got this.
Don't worry.
It's okay.
Rewind.
I rewind.
No one will know.
He'll...
It's just his previous life.
He's fine.
Okay, that should not hit him.
see wait what I said it hit him there you go easy thank you for saving us I was getting so tired being pushed up messed up it's okay it's okay I rewind it I had like a I had like a you know like like in that Rick and Morty episode I do a bad thing and then I just press a button and like everyone's still alive I'm just letting my intrusive thoughts win,
but like no consequences, though.
Look, it's your fault for getting kidnapped.
I was getting so tired of being pushed around by these robot goons.
Yeah, yeah, where can we find other dragoons?
Most of them were put to work in the factory.
It's not far, but you need to get through the guards.
We got this.
No, you're still alive.
It's just your previous life versions.
Maybe you weren't so lucky.
If you're sure.
Look, I whiffed my shot, okay?
It happens.
Is it really my...
I just whiffed my shot, guys.
It happens to everybody.
Oops, that was actually...
Okay.
Yeah.
Give me a sec.
Simple geometry time.
Oh my god, there's so many geometries though.
It nearly happens to everybody, guys.
I'm just seeing if I can do this without using the box.
Okay.
All right, let's see.
I mean, it is possible for some of the solutions without having to use the box.
Okay, we got to use the box.
Fine.
Okay.
And that.
All right, we got to push you up.
Ding.
And that hits that.
That hits that.
And what happened?
Okay.
That hits that and then that hits that and then how the fuck?
I don't know that.
Hmm.
Oh my god, what the fuck is this solution?
I'm thinking.
Oh my gosh, she's done bing-bonging.
I don't know, actually.
Okay, wait.
Do that.
And then...
I'm analyzing.
I'm analyzing right now.
Maybe like this.
I...
How did it not hit you?
Okay, wait.
I think that is how you do it.
Oh, shit.
Okay, well, let's try it.
I thought it hit you.
hit him.
It looked like it hit him.
Ah, fuck it.
I already fucked it up anyway.
Alright.
Okay.
Bing.
Bong.
Okay.
You need to be able to hit this, too.
Oh my god, this one's difficult.
Okay.
This is actually full-on simple geometry.
Okay, maybe?
No.
Oh, that's so close.
God damn it!
Bing!
Bingo!
I just shot that.
Bing!
How the fuck?
Maybe Bond?
Because I don't think this hits him.
Maybe here?
Maybe that...
Oh, wait, no.
Oh, my.
This is really difficult.
Oh, my God.
Please.
Or do I ping-bong?
God.
God damn it.
No, no, no.
We don't need a walkthrough.
Bing.
Oh,
it shows.
Oh, okay.
Okay, maybe.
Maybe.
Okay, it's just this.
God damn it.
Oh, this is so difficult.
Maybe I'll move this here.
Alright.
I should have to think.
Bing bong.
Thinking hard.
Really not meant to do so much thinking.
Oh my god, that was so close.
Wait, I think this is it.
I fucked up.
Oh my god.
All right.
Okay.
This way?
And then this way.
I've had it.
I just got a simple geometry this.
And then it's over.
Holy shit.
Okay.
What?
What the fuck?
Okay.
I'm just like, what the fuck?
I don't know.
Why you don't rotate the way I want you to?
I'll never know.
What the fuck?
It's just this one!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's this.
Oh my god, it did it.
Simple geometry.
BAM!
Looks like those bullets are more than enough after all.
Because I'm such a gamer.
Sick.
Okay, nobody was counting.
Man, nobody was counting.
Well, at least 10 I think.
I need you so much.
I see what the Drangu's meant.
Their armors look thick.
You might have to hit them a couple of times to break through.
I need not have bullets for this.
Guess we have to try hard this.
Oh my god, okay.
How many times do I have to hit them?
Wait, how many times do I have to hit them?
Oh, no.
Okay, man, I can't believe I missed that, guys.
Holy shit,
that was crazy.
Okay.
Wait,
there's Metal Gear references?
Guys, I am the wrong person to figure that out.
I didn't even realize there was Metal Gear.
I'm just like, what?
What do you mean there was Metal Gear references?
I am the wrong V-Tuber.
Except notice the Metal Gear.
There we go.
Yay!
Okay, this one was a lot easier.
This place looked kind of haunted.
Don't say that.
I don't have any liquid courage.
Oh, is that Metal Gear?
Is that a Metal Gear reference?
To help me out this time.
Look, I did it!
I saw the Metal Gear reference!
Wow, there's a lot of warning signs around here.
Maybe we can use these guys because they're so dangerous.
Okay.
What do I do?
Wait, what do I do here?
What the fuck?
Oh!
I see
Fun I don't know I don't know maybe this Yeah
Oh fucking Oh one guy I got one guy I got one guy You stupid one guy You You You You Not the one guy.
You.
I was like, yay!
And then I got one guy.
Always one guy.
I was like, whoa, I did it!
I don't even know what I did.
That's the worst part.
What the fuck did I do?
Oh, this is the only way.
Oh my god.
was not the only way.
I don't know.
I'm just pushing random stuff.
Oh my god, this is so difficult.
Oh, look at this.
I always get one guy.
You.
Of course.
Okay, we gotta do it so that we kill him.
There.
Oh, that doesn't activate him.
I thought it did.
He's just a chill guy.
I refuse to let him chill.
He must die.
Oh my god.
Why would someone make a dokeeper game that requires?
This is the game for the people.
They made a game for the people.
Oh my god.
I hate him.
It's just this one guy.
It's literally just him.
He's actually ruining my entire run.
This little fucker.
It's him!
Oh my god, I don't know what to do I don't know what to do
Maybe like this I won't kill him No, I can't kill him Oh, I have more beings
Okay, I don't know I think I messed that up
Yeah, I already messed that up You You!
I don't know, maybe here?
I don't know, I don't know what I'm doing.
Wait, unless...
Oh my god, it needs to kill him.
Like, that's the worst part.
Please, it needs to kill him and also everything else.
Oh my god, please.
I need you to kill him and everything else.
This is it.
Yes!
Yes, I did it!
Fuck you!
I'm getting one guy no more.
Too easy.
Oh, wait.
Where are those two doing back here?
Focus on the mission, Doki.
You can think about Drake.
Okay.
All right.
How do we save him?
Oh.
Okay.
How do we...
It was an accident.
I swear.
I swear to God.
That was an accident.
I pushed this.
I swear to God.
I swear.
Oh yeah.
okay i have i there's no way i can push yeah i can't push i shouldn't push him into it
okay i have to make it so that it keeps bouncing
okay all you have to do is not hit okay there you go
it has to hit that box and then it should be five There we go.
Okay.
Oh my god.
This one is...
Because like, I don't want to kill the dragon there.
I'm not...
Every time I accident killed him, it was an accident.
We all know that.
It was all an accident.
Yeah, because like...
If I push it here, he'll die to these guys.
So I have to push it this way.
Oh my god.
Oh, come on!
Ruined their love!
Oh, that was so close.
I almost shot.
I almost got him.
Okay.
Where the fuck are you?
That was so close.
I don't even know which is how I got that shot, to be fair.
There you go.
Right in the middle.
Where did my bullet go?
It was right in the middle.
Where did the bullet go?
I swear to God.
I assume that.
I assume that was.
It wasn't gonna happen.
Oh my god.
Simple geometry is so hard.
Guys, I swear to you guys, it wasn't that.
That was not what I assumed.
Okay, right here.
Okay, not right.
Not right there.
I'm sorry.
Where is it?
I just want to kill you.
I don't understand.
I have to push this up because of the explosion.
Push this box in?
But what about the explosion?
Look he's in it.
He's in the...
The...
Last area.
Bye, Dad.
Literally him.
I get one more push, really?
No, I don't.
See?
Yeah.
I was gonna
say, I'm pretty sure I don't get one more push.
Maybe here.
Oh, shit.
here okay oh my god geometry is so hard oh my god where the fuck is my bullets going this way are you serious
It's okay, Doki.
I was never good at geology.
I don't know.
I don't know!
I can't.
If I push him up and I kill him, they blast, they blast him.
See this?
God damn it hit.
Oh, wait, no, if that hit it, it would, like, do it, uh...
Eventually, if I brute force it enough, something will work.
Podwatch, you skip 30 minutes.
Something will happen.
Okay.
I got this.
Here we go.
Okay, no.
Are we here?
Like, I don't know where it's ending.
No, the devs said I'm moving the right box.
It's literally wherever I'm positioning.
It's like my positioning is what I have to figure out.
So I know I'm moving the right box.
out simple geometry.
Oh my god.
I swear to god.
Please.
It's not.
It's not easy.
I was never good at geometry, guys.
I did it!
I Oh my god, I did.
Finally.
Finally, Doki, you're back.
I'm sorry, this is all my fault.
Hey, don't go stealing credit for my kills.
No, I mean, we caused this.
You're gone for so long, and we really miss you.
Take that geometry.
Jeez, what happened to you all?
Hello?
Oh my god, my voice is dying.
I guess if he doesn't want to answer, there's only one way to find out.
Wait, guys, how many more levels are there?
As Doki and men enter a room, a low feminine voice rings out.
So you finally arrive, Doki bird.
There is 12?
Guys, oh, three more?
Okay.
Are you the one behind all this?
Give me back my dragoons.
Oh, is this Doki?
Do you really deserve them?
What do you mean?
I came all the way here and beat your robots just to get them back.
The shouted figure walks forward and yet they made me like...
Huh?
They did what?
Oh, I should have left them here.
What is that?
Why are you so...
Very, very low track goes.
Jingle, jingle.
You get the picture.
Jingle, jingle?
Okay.
But why did you kidnap them?
I'm a robot.
I gotta try taking over the world.
That's like our whole thing.
Okay, you gotta put...
Guys, why fight peace and love?
There could be both of us.
Guys, two jingles.
jangles.
Think about it, chat.
We can get four jingles, guys.
Two is better than one.
And you know what's better than two?
Four.
Okay, you got a point there.
We're still going to take you down, though.
Give me back my dragon so I can punish them for being unfaithful.
Come on, then.
Let's see what you've got.
Sorry, I have nothing on, but if you could have to, you could convince us, but thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, guys.
My voice is actually feeling very... Okay, wait.
What happens when I just shoot her?
Okay, nothing happens.
Okay.
How many... Guys, Okay, I think my voice is feeling incredibly...
I'm so sorry.
I really want to finish this.
We'll do it.
We'll finish it tomorrow.
I'm not tomorrow.
Sorry.
We'll finish it next week, guys.
We'll finish it next week.
But my voice is feeling very strange right now.
So I have to call it.
And I know that you guys really want me to finish this.
We will finish this game, but I think I'm really pushing it with my voice.
So I'm going to call it here.
And like, I don't really want to shoot Dough Kitty right now.
So I'm really sorry.
I, my voice is really feeling incredibly strained right now.
So I'm going to, I have to, I have for the sake of my throat, for the sake of my throat, I will finish it next week.
But thank you guys.
Oh my God.
It was really, really fun.
It was so fun checking.
Actually, no.
Instead of finishing, I could just watch the thing.
We'll watch the dokey proof because I don't think we...
I think I'm going to struggle.
Actually, you're right.
Maybe I should just watch it.
All right.
Let's just...
Let's just watch the solution.
Where is it?
All right.
It's like, it's like I'm playing the game.
It's almost like I'm playing the game, guys.
Alright, let's see it.
Oh.
Tied this.
Wait.
Alright.
Okay, let's fix this real quick.
Nope.
God damn it.
Uh.
Where is it?
Where the fuck?
Okay.
Let me.
a sec I have to reset there you go it's just easier guys you don't understand it it's just easier no more geometry no more geometry guys Okay, let me see.
There we go.
For the sake of my mental health.
I don't want to get one guy no more.
I don't want to get one guy.
Alright.
Here we go.
Bing Bong Guys I'm playing right now Guys look at me go
Alright Look that's me I'm playing That's me right here Oh that's me
Oh my god I did it I did it Nice try but I'm not done yet Robo Doki lunges towards Doki The claw sinking in dragging her off the catwalk to the factory floor below joki pushes away from a robot nemesis as they land on the assembly line rolling back to get out of range she's tough huh first try guys first try
bing fine oh my god guys watch this i'm gonna first try this too watch this
look at this guys so cool
That's fucking crazy.
First try.
The conveyor belt shifts.
Robo-Doki quickly jumps off.
Running and cowering.
Robo-goons, protect me!
I'm so good.
Holy shit.
Wait, I am a gamer.
How is she so good at...
Guys, I went back to school just to retake geometry, guys.
Now, why else am I in my schoolgirl outfit?
I went back to school just for geometry.
Okay, you made it.
pass soon, but this isn't even my final form.
Let's see how you like this.
Robo-Doki strikes the pose.
Her insides were and buzz.
Panel sliding is clicking in the place.
Excuse me?
In a blinding flash, Robo-Doki disappears and is replaced by...
What's your face, by?
What the fuck?
Exactly the same...
Wait, that wasn't supposed to happen.
Those dragoons They built me wrong.
I don't know.
I think they did a pretty good job.
You still have way more hits than anyone else.
What the fuck?
You did a pretty good job.
Oh, come on.
Don't tell me.
No, I'm just saying.
Your design is pretty cool.
Jingle, jingle, jingle.
Yes, my design.
Totally.
Doki walks towards Robo Doki reaching out.
So, like, look at this accent.
It's so...
Yeah, yeah, the accent.
accent hey don't get so close and what if i do robo dokey are you some kind of um i am a robo connoisseur okay i'm here to appreciate the fine details i know how you feel about robots don't even try to hide it that's not important what you're literally what
I admit it's watching in the chair right now as Toki and her robot.
I can't.
I don't...